It's not about perfection,
just like my diet is not perfect.
It's imperfect.
And this is about adopting a diet
that is as plant exclusive as possible.
(upbeat music)
If we want to see great changes in public health,
we want to see great changes in planetary health,
if we want to minimize the unnecessary pain
and suffering that we're inflicting,
then we need billions of people doing this imperfectly.
Start slowly, remove the self-judgment,
and just get started.
I probably don't have to tell you
that the internet is just rife with misinformation
when it comes to nutrition,
which ends up paralyzing the average person
when it comes to just making simple,
well-informed, better decisions about their health.
Well, back to once again,
help us parse fact from fiction, and guide us
towards a more rational science-backed model
for or nutritional wellbeing,
today marks round two with Simon Hill.
Simon is the host of the fantastic "Plant Proof" podcast,
and blog of the same name.
He's the plant-based food contributor
to Chris Hemsworth's fitness app, Centr.
And he's the author of "The Proof is in the Plants,"
which is a truly fantastic evidence-based primer
on the positive impact of a plant predominant diet.
This conversation picks up, where RRP 638
from early November of 2021, left off,
digging deeper into very specific,
practical, and actionable aspects of nutrition
based upon the latest and best science,
including caloric density versus nutritional density,
The importance of specific enumerated nutrients,
the differences between plant and animal protein,
what the latest science says about the health implications
of plant-based meat products.
We also talk about the best ways
to transition to a more plant-forward diet.
We talk about specific fueling
and supplementation strategies for building strength
and athletic performance, and many other interesting topics.
Personally, I find Simon to be a highly credible authority
with just a really grounded and balanced perspective
on a subject, I think we would all agree, can be
at times, quite emotionally charged.
And I just appreciate the rigor
that he brings to this field.
And this conversation is chockablock
with important information,
and as I mentioned, very actionable takeaways
for anyone looking to just level up their plate.
Finally, Simon has also provided
a robust index of all studies
referenced in this conversation,
hyperlinks to which you can find in the show notes
on the episode page at richroll.com.
So put on your propeller hat,
do me a solid by hitting that subscribe button.
And here we go, round two with Simon Hill.
Simon, good to see you.
Happy to have you back in on the tail end
of your epic United States extended stay.
I know you're headed back to Australia soon,
so we had to get you back in here before you skedaddle
for round two, how are you feeling today?
Very good, thank you for having me.
I feel like I'm almost a resident here now.
I know you've been here,
how long have you been here at this point?
What was meant to be four weeks has turned
into three months?
So it's been fun though.
The states is essentially my second home.
So it's been fun hanging out and catching up with you,
and getting out to the desert and spending time with Doug.
You went out there twice, right?
Twice, yeah.
Out near Joshua Tree, which is a, it's a fantastic area.
And we had a lot of fun exploring the park there
and soaking in the hot springs.
In his tubs?
Yeah.
Eating lots of sprouts.
I just had Mike Posner in here recently
And he went out there as well,
and came back a complete sprouting fanatic.
And now all of his social media is monopolized by sprouting.
It's a spell.
If you spend time with Doug,
you will end up sprouting
and your kitchen will turn into a sprout file.
I'll do that.
Well, I couldn't let you go back home
without getting you back in here.
The initial episode that we did together was super popular,
people really dug it.
And we talked a little bit about
how we wanted to handle this.
And I think the idea that we came up
with was making this a much more
kind of focused, pinpointed conversation.
Our first conversation was relatively broad.
We covered your backstory, your personal story.
We looked at the hierarchy of evidence and scientific study.
We talked about diet war tribalism.
We took a look at the science that supports
a plant-based diet, the microbiome.
We talked about saturated fat,
the environmental implications of diet and food choice.
Many other topics.
If you have not listened to
or watched that episode, it's number 638,
please make a point of doing it.
It's fantastic.
But today we're gonna pursue
a much more full focused discussion directed
towards, mostly towards those who are
either already eating a plant-based diet,
keen on adopting a more plant-centric diet,
or looking to improve upon their plant-based diet
with the goal of essentially setting yourself up
for success.
And I think the first thing that I want to get into
or where we can start, would be to begin
with common blind spots.
So let's say, okay, Simon,
I've been eating a plant-based diet
for six months, or a year.
How do I know I'm doing it right?
What are some of the common things that trip people up
or where they go astray, before they have kind of
the full encyclopedic knowledge of how to do this properly?
There's probably two or three main things
that I've identified anyway,
in working with many people are going through this,
and also through my own experience
and talking to people like you.
I think the first is understanding when you are minimizing
or removing these animal foods that we have grown accustomed
to eating all the time.
What do you replace them with?
Because there's a lot of different options.
Everything from black beans and lentils
to very processed vegan foods.
The second would be understanding the difference
between an animal-based diet and a plant-based diet
in terms of calorie density.
So animal foods are typically much more calorie-dense,
and therefore, if you're wanting to eat
a similar number of calories,
your plate needs to look fuller
when it's plant-based foods.
I mean, that's a pretty common thing that you hear like,
"Oh, I tried it, but I was starving all the time."
Yes, and that is something that I personally experienced.
So as I was making these changes,
I was not fully cognizant of
the differences in calorie density.
And I was experiencing in the very beginning
of my transition, a little drop in energy.
And I was doubting whether
the plant-based foods were working for me.
And really it was just
that I was not consuming enough overall calories.
So understanding what to replace animal foods with,
calorie density, and then the third I'd say, is having
a general awareness of specific nutrients of focus.
So all diets, whether it's an omnivorous diet
or a plant-based diet, need to be appropriately planned,
or they can fall short.
And, if we look around at our current sort
of state of health, the omnivorous diet's
not really serving us that well,
it has a number of holes and gaps.
And while a plant-based diet can really
improve your overall disease risk profile.
And we spoke a lot about that in terms of
shifting these biomarkers in a favorable direction,
your cholesterol, your blood glucose control,
inflammation, blood pressure,
and lower your risk of these chronic diseases
that are plaguing our society.
At the same time, there are a few nutrients
that you need to be aware of,
so that are getting them in the required amounts,
to not just prevent your risk of
these chronic diseases longterm,
but to really optimize yourself
and feel at your best in your day-to-day.
So the obvious next question being,
what are those nutrients?
Yeah.
So I call these nutrients of focus, and I think
that's a positive spin on nutrients of concern.
And I just, I want people,
I wanna draw people's attention to them.
In the book I write about eight of these,
and some of are quite easy to get
through your diet and/or fortified foods,
and then others are best accessed through a supplement.
So as a list, these are vitamin B12,
vitamin D, omega-3 fatty acids, iodine,
iron, calcium, zinc, and selenium.
Right.
So given that, a skeptic would say, well,
if I have to pay extra close attention to these things,
or I have to go outside of my food
that I'm consuming and supplement,
then this must be a deficient diet by definition.
I think we need to zoom out a little bit
and understand that nutritional gaps are nothing new.
And it's the very reason that folate
and iodine have been used throughout the food system,
fortifying foods to prevent iodine deficiency
and folate deficiency in the general public.
So this idea of fortificational supplements is nothing new
and lots of those nutrients I just reeled off,
like zinc, selenium, iron, calcium,
you can easily access them through your diet
and you don't need to supplement those.
It's just a matter of understanding what foods do you want
to be incorporating in your diet regularly?
And for example, if you're choosing a plant-based milk
to swap out dairy, which is rich in calcium,
what should you be looking for?
And I would add to that,
that I understand there are certain people
that are very anti-supplements and therefore,
that must make this the incorrect diet
for optimal health and wellbeing.
But not everything that is unnatural is bad for us.
And there have been many parts of our life,
be it modern housing or climate control,
that have improved our wellbeing,
so I think just presuming that everything
that is natural is best is somewhat of a fallacy.
And what we should be worried most
about is heart health outcomes.
So I have nothing against a diet
that includes some supplementation.
It means the best outcomes for,
be it for myself or anyone that I'm working with.
And that is what the data suggests.
If you wanna move down this path of very plant-rich,
plant-predominant diets, or even plant-exclusive
to lower your risk of chronic disease,
then taking some of these supplements is going
to allow you to do that in a more optimal manner.
Right.
Certainly things like vitamin D deficiencies
are not endemic to the plant-based community.
I mean, this is something that omnivores,
that a lot of people, perhaps even the majority of people
who are not living on the equator experience, right?
Sure, and you could say the same about vitamin B12.
There was a study done recently,
an American population over 3,000 people and 39% of
the omnivores in there had insufficient B12 status.
So you're right, the nutritional deficiencies
are not just something that plant-predominant
or plant-exclusive eaters experience.
And I think we could all agree
that the supplement industry,
the billion dollar supplement industry,
is not propped up by vegans.
So there's a bit to sort of weigh up there,
but the most important thing that I kind of,
the point that I wanna make here,
is that most of this is very easily covered.
And it's just a matter of taking some time
to get across the information.
And then you set and forget,
and you focus on the overall quality of your diet,
and you have a few supplements or fortified foods,
and you can have peace of mind that you're
getting everything that you need in required amounts.
One question that I've always had,
and I'm not sure I've ever asked it to anybody,
certainly nobody of your experience.
Is there a difference between taking
like a specific B12 supplement,
either a spray or a sublingual, or something like that,
and a D and a zinc, whatever,
taking those individually versus getting
a really good multivitamin
that has kind of everything in it?
This is a great question.
And some of this comes down to
the person we're talking about.
I know that some people
who are completely okay with supplements,
will be happy just taking a multivitamin,
knowing that a lot of those nutrients in there,
they're already getting in the amounts that they require.
Right, you get the bright yellow pee.
Yeah, so a lot of the B vitamins,
you're already getting a lot of those
through a very plant-rich diet,
particularly folate, for example,
you're getting it in abundance.
You don't really need to be supplementing that,
but some people just like to take a multivitamin
and that's okay.
I am an advocate for taking a multivitamin,
if that's the path you want to go down.
There are some things to think about with the multivitamins
because they're not all formulated for plant-predominant,
plant-rich people.
So there are some things to look at specifically,
and then others prefer to take individual supplements,
which can mean having to buy multiple different supplements.
And it's not as convenient,
but there are a number of brands now coming out
that are creating multi-nutrients,
specific for the needs of someone who is adopting
a plant-based dietary pattern.
Like Matt Frazier has a multivitamin
that's sort of specific to people
who are eating a plant-based diet.
That's directed towards the nutrients
that perhaps you might be lacking.
Yeah, and I think those are great options
because they've done the work,
they've realized you don't need all of these other vitamins
and minerals you're already getting,
and they've worked out calculated through science,
so data-driven,
how much of each of these nutrients are focused,
do you actually need, and therefore
you end up with a more personalized supplement.
So with respect to B12,
there's different types of that, there's methylcobalamin
and then there's cobalamin,
like which one should you be selecting?
And hydroxycobalamin, and adeno, so cobalamin.
It all gets very confusing.
My position is that the most-studied version
is cyanocobalamin and, for preventing deficiency
and reversing it.
And therefore the dosages that we have,
the recommended amounts of B12 to take
are largely from studies looking at that type.
So my recommendation is to buy
a sciatica-balumin B12 supplement,
and you'd be looking at 250 micrograms daily,
or two and a half thousand micrograms once a week.
Those are your two options.
Now I should add to that.
If you are a smoker or you have kidney disease,
that's two instances where methylcobalamin
is certainly better.
And then I would also add, if your supplement
contains methylcobalamin,
I have worked with many people
who have used that form and have completely fine B12 status,
so they all seem to work.
My preference being cyanocobalamin is purely
because that's what most of the science has looked at.
Because it's more bio available or it converts better?
Well, it tends to be used in the studies more
because it's cheaper,
and more widely available.
But we have seen it in the last, I'd say five or so years,
a lot more brands you using methylcobalamin.
And I think that's okay.
My recommendation for most of this stuff
is your laboratory tests will really tell the story.
Yeah, and that's a great objective way
of keeping an eye on any of these nutrients,
and just periodically keeping
an eye on your overall health.
I think it's a good idea with B12,
it's worth mentioning,
if you're doing a blood test,
the standard blood test that your physician
would order is serum B12.
And that's a pretty good marker, but it's not perfect.
There are active and inactive B12 molecules in our body.
And the serum B12 test does pick up
some of the inactive analogs.
And so the general rule of thumb is
if you get a serum B12 test, and it comes back,
and you're at the middle or upper part of the range,
then you probably don't need
to look into things any further.
But if you're more towards the lower end
of the normal range, then there is another test
called MMA that you can request,
which is more specific and sensitive to active B12.
So, most people won't need to worry about that,
but that's one just to be mindful of,
if your B12 is little low,
and perhaps you are subjectively feeling
like you don't have a lot of energy.
And when we're talking about vitamin D,
is there a difference between D and D3,
or are those terms conflated?
Those are the same thing.
D3 is the type of vitamin D
that your body will produce following sun exposure.
And it's also found
in animal products, and found in plant lichen,
which is a type of algae.
And then there is D2, which is found in mushrooms,
but D2 or D3
will both increase your vitamin D status.
It's important to add that 80,
90% of your vitamin D status is determined by sun exposure.
So very little contribution from the foods
that we eat, and that status,
it be really affected by how dark your skin is,
that where you live in the world.
If you live at a Northern latitude, you are more at risk
of developing vitamin D deficiency.
What is the, what are the symptoms of,
how does that manifest?
It could be an impaired immune system
is one of the main ones.
And so whether someone needs to supplement vitamin D
is debated around the world heavily.
And even the reference ranges
are heavily debated country-to-country.
My general sort of advice here is
unless you're getting daily sun exposure,
and that sun exposure, the rule of thumb is
about half of the time it would take
for you to burn is the amount of time in the sun
it would take to produce adequate amount of vitamin D.
Yeah, I mean, translation is the sun exposure required
to produce inadequate amount of vitamin D is much more
than I think people think.
And as I said, if you have darker skin pigmentation,
you need to be in the sun for longer to produce
the same amount of vitamin D as someone with fairer skin.
And this is why we see people with darker skin
more at risk of vitamin D deficiency.
So you can do a hydroxy vitamin D test
and determine whether you are low
or you're at a healthy level.
That could be your starting point.
And so someone like you here in Los Angeles
and myself in Sydney, sun exposure may be completely fine.
It might be adequate for us.
But then someone living in the United Kingdom
or perhaps, part of Canada, it could be a little different.
And if you are on the low side,
the general rule of thumb for supplementation
is about 1,000 to 2,000 IU.
And there are a few different vitamin D supplements
out there, as I mentioned.
So a lot of them are actually not plant-based.
They're derived from wool.
So if you are looking for one.
I didn't know that.
If you're looking for one that is vegan,
if that's important to you,
then you want to find either vitamin D3 from plant lichen,
and essentially any brand selling vitamin D3
that is vegan will call out vegan on the packaging.
Or, the other option is vitamin D2 from mushroom.
Is there a specific brand that you recommend
or you steer clear of that?
I generally do steer a little clear
of recommending brands.
However, I will say, because I'm asked this all the time,
I have put together a PDF, and I'm kind of nearly finished.
It's been a huge project
because trying to find the right supplements
depending on someone's age or whether their lifestyle stage,
for example, prenatal,
and then looking what's available around the entire world.
I can send you that PDF,
and you can perhaps put that on your website.
Yeah, maybe we can link that up in the show notes,
'cause this isn't going up for a while.
So maybe by then you'll be done with it.
I will be done by then,
but I have been reluctant to kind of associate
with too many brands in the past,
but it is such a regular question I get,
that I kind of thought, well,
I need to go through this process.
So that will definitely be made available.
And I should just add to this
that if someone is overweight or obese,
their requirement for vitamin D is actually higher.
So in that instance, it can require sort of two to 3,000 IU
to achieve a healthy vitamin D status.
So worth just keeping in mind.
Two questions.
Is there any reason or efficacy behind,
like megadosing any of these, like is there
a minimum effective dose in that you're,
once you meet your requirements, you're good?
Or, is there any added benefit
from taking over that amount is the first question.
And then the second is, if you are deficient,
how long does it to restore your balance?
I assume it's not just one vitamin and then you're good.
Like it's gonna take a while, right?
Yeah, weeks, weeks to months, it can take,
depending on the nutrient that we're talking about,
and how low someone is and what dose you give them.
megadosing, look, I would not be recommending doing that
unless it's under the guidance of your physician
and there's a very compelling reason to be doing that.
You hear all sorts of things and ideas online,
like megadosing vitamin D, for example,
the upper limit of vitamin D is set
at about 3,000 to 4,000 IU in Australia.
And the sort of studies looking at toxicity
have shown that up to 10,000 IU is still safe.
However, I think given that the published upper limit
is I believe 4,000 IU,
I would be hesitant to recommend anyone does that megadosing
without their physician overlooking it.
All right, got it.
You mentioned iodine earlier
in this list of eight nutrients.
So why is that important and what are
the foods that we should be looking at
to make sure that we're meeting our iodine needs?
Yeah, this one's often forgotten.
And so it deserves a bit more air time.
So iodine is integral to our thyroid hormone production,
which regulates our metabolism.
And there are quite a few papers now
that have shown pescatarians, vegetarians,
and vegans tend to have lower iodine status.
There are three ways to easily get iodine in your diet,
you just need to be aware of them.
And the first is seaweed.
So dulse and wakame, nori sheets,
these are loaded with iodine.
And to give you an idea,
the recommended daily intake of iodine is 150 micrograms,
it's tiny, this is a trace mineral.
You only need a tiny, tiny amount.
And to reach that 150 micrograms,
you would need about two teaspoons
of dulse or wakame, fics, or one nori sheet.
There are different views of that as a strategy
that I see out there,
and usually that's pertaining to the fact that
the iodine content of seaweed around the world does vary.
So that's just something to keep in mind.
And you can do a urinary iodine test
if you wanted to check your status at any stage.
The second option and is an option where you would know
you're definitely getting 150 micrograms, is iodized salt.
And you would need, depending on the brand,
it's usually about half a teaspoon of iodized salt
would provide 150 micrograms.
You really need to turn it around
and read the label to determine that serve.
Now the sort of potential downside
of that strategy, is that that comes
with 1,000 milligrams of sodium,
and the RDA of sodium is around 2,000.
So it could be an okay strategy,
let's say for someone who's doing a lot of exercise
and sweating, and has healthy blood pressure,
but for someone with even
moderately raised blood pressure,
or certainly someone with hypertension,
then, that's not going to be the best option for them.
I would add to that,
and I just read about this a couple weeks ago
and I'm super glad I read it,
there was a big study in China that was published,
it must have been about five or six months ago now.
And it was actually done,
it was a collaboration between
a university in Sydney and some Chinese researchers.
And they did this big randomized controlled trial looking
at cardiovascular disease, specifically stroke in China.
And what they were looking at was if you swap salt,
traditional salt out for what's called Lite Salt,
which instead of being completely sodium chloride,
it's a potassium chloride,
which gives you a very similar taste,
but unlike sodium, potassium lowers blood pressure.
And they did find that that simple swap,
swapping to this what's called Lo Salt or Lite Salt,
those are two brands that are available,
which now do iodized salt,
is a great option for someone
who maybe does have moderately high blood pressure.
I never heard of that, is that available?
It's available.
Outside of China?
Yes, so I wanted to make sure.
I thought it could come up today.
I wanted to make sure.
So you can literally go online
and search Lo Salt or Lite Salt.
You'll find Amazon, all of the major retailers have it.
I'm not sure what grocery supermarkets have it
on the shelves here, but it's definitely available.
And it reduces the sodium per serve, by between 30 and 60%.
So that's a sort of a good option
for getting iodine into your diet.
If blood pressure's not an issue, is iodized salt.
I think now knowing the availability of Lo Salt,
that even if you have healthy blood pressure
and you opt for an iodized salt,
you may as well get the Lo Salt.
And it tastes the same.
Yes.
Well, or similar.
I read some reviews and they were,
the reviews sections are always quite entertaining
and there were some colorful messages in there,
but the majority of people seemed to think
that it was similar and sort of like for like,
so that's a potential option.
The third option goes back to what you said earlier around,
is just taking a multi-nutrient the best way to go?
And you can get a single
sort of isolated iodine supplement by itself.
And that will provide 150 micrograms, or you can,
you'll find it in pretty much all multivitamins
at that input level.
And I should caveat, I guess, as well,
now that I think about it,
these numbers I'm talking about are for healthy adults.
Some of this changes, if you are pregnant or breastfeeding,
for example, the amount of iodine you need
bumps up to in the 200s.
So just keep that in mind.
But when you are working with a dietician or physician,
they'll be able to direct you into,
towards a correct dose.
And is iodine deficiency something
that you're gonna find more frequently
on a plant-based diet versus an omnivorous diet?
Yes, so if you are not having dairy,
which contains a little bit of iodine, and seafood, you are,
unless you are eating a lot of food with the iodized salt,
you are more at risk of experiencing deficiency.
So, certainly, and I kind of alluded to this at the start,
this has been one of the nutrients
that probably hasn't had enough air time.
And you have those three options.
I think they're pretty easy to plan for,
so this doesn't need to be an issue.
It's just being aware of it,
realizing you only need a trace,
it's a very small amount you need, and just working out
what option are you going for?
One, two, three, and then set and forget.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is, most people I know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire
to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans,
and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say, is "The Plantpower Meal Planner,"
our affordable all-in-one digital platform that sets you up
for nutrition excellence by providing access
to thousands of highly customizable, super delicious,
and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life changing stuff,
people, for just a $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
A common fear that a lot of people have
when considering a plant-based diet is calcium.
Oh my goodness,
if I don't eat dairy, I'm not drinking milk,
my bones are gonna turn brittle.
Where am I gonna get my calcium?
My understanding is that dark leafy greens are
a pretty good source of calcium.
I've never had an issue with this,
but how do you think about that,
and ensuring that people are meeting their calcium needs?
Firstly, I would say that building strong bones
is a team game.
We've reduced it very much to just calcium,
but it's so much more than that.
And even before talking about nutrition,
I think it's worth emphasizing that exercise is arguably
far, far more important, both impact exercise,
so we're talking about jogging or skipping,
going up and downstairs or hopping,
that sort of impact exercise is a stimulus.
The body, structure reflects function.
And so it responds to that by laying down more bone,
increasing your bone mineral density.
And then the second type of exercise, resistance training.
So be it lower body, things like squats,
or upper body with bands,
the research is pretty, pretty clear
that we need to be doing this stuff regularly
for as long as possible to prevent significant amount
of bone loss, which does naturally occur as you age.
But you wanna slow that down.
Yeah, there's some interesting studies out there
about lack of bone density or bone loss in elite cyclists,
because there's no impact,
despite the fact that there are incredibly fit,
there's an issue with that.
And that's a great point.
So cycling and swimming are incredible
from a cardiovascular point-of-view,
but they're not loading the bone in the same way.
So it's not really about either, or,
you want to be working both cardiovascular exercise
in as well as this impact resistance training.
And there is a lot of studies showing, for example,
with osteopenia or osteoporosis,
osteopenia being kind of like pre-diabetes is
to type two diabetes.
You go, you first.
Osteopenia being a precursor to osteoporosis.
You sort of go through that phase usually first,
but there is a lot of research looking at this.
And it's clear that just walking, for example,
is not enough to prevent that bone loss
and to prevent getting to a point
where you have an osteoporotic fracture,
and one in two people in this country
and in Australia, aged over 50,
will have an osteoporotic fracture.
So this is an incredibly important conversation.
So to your, the start of this,
and to answer your question more directly,
calcium is important, and the recommended daily intake
around the world, it varies country-to-country.
Again, it's another one where people
really haven't settled on a kind of universal figure.
The World Health Organization start at 500 milligrams a day
and the United Kingdom is about 700 milligrams a day.
And then there are other countries like Australia
and the United States, where it's
between 1,000 and 1,300 milligrams per day.
And I was really interested in kind of understanding
the data and why there is confusion.
And what I landed on was consistently,
it seems that you need to be consuming
at least 700 milligrams, which is in line
with the United Kingdom recommendations,
as a way of preventing the development
of osteopenia or osteoporosis.
And what I can tell you is that when you look across
all of the different population studies,
looking at vegetarian and vegan cohorts,
they are consistently getting that much calcium on average.
So on average, they're getting that,
but whenever you look at an average, you,
we need to be aware that
there are going to be people falling below.
So it is still something to be aware of.
And you're right,
these foods like dark leafy greens
and also your cruciferous vegetables, like broccoli,
but also seeds, like sesame seeds and tahini,
these are very, very rich in calcium.
My recommendation is to add a plant-based milk to your diet
that has calcium in it.
Fortified with calcium.
Fortified, with calcium.
And in my experience, working with a lot of people,
this is a nice way to sort of bulletproof the diet
and ensure that you're getting over 700 milligrams.
And my general advice is to look for
a plant-based milk that has
at least 100 milligrams of calcium per 150 mils.
And what that means is when you have a cup
or a cup and a half, you'll be getting three,
400 milligrams of calcium.
And by the time you've had all of your fruits
and vegetables, and legumes, and nuts and seeds,
you are well above the 700 milligram
sort of threshold where we want to be.
But as I kind of alluded to, this is a team game,
and you can have as much calcium in your diet as you want,
and still develop osteoporosis.
And we know that because countries that drink
the most milk have the highest rates of osteoporosis.
So--
What is that attributable to?
So it speaks to the fact that it is a team game,
and there, we do see that countries
that are consuming the most dairy
also have the lowest vitamin D status,
will tend to, and vitamin D is crucial
for bone mineral density, because it actually enhances
the absorption of calcium in your diet.
So if you're deficient in vitamin D,
you will absorb less calcium.
So building strong bones,
you need to make sure you're a cross vitamin D.
You are hitting this calcium threshold hold,
but then also vitamin B12,
which we spoke about, integral, and protein.
And if you're covering all of those bases
and you are doing the exercise, then that is all going
to sort of coalesce to really reduce your risk
of developing quote unquote, "weak bones."
So load-bearing exercise, vitamin D,
and calcium all work in tandem.
And I mentioned protein, and this is partly why
the recommendations for protein as someone gets
to sort of 50, 60 goes up a little bit,
and this is mostly to do with trying to slow down
this rate of bone mineral density loss,
but also to slow down the rate of muscle loss.
And I'm sure we might speak in a minute about protein
and what that looks like.
Yeah, I wanna dive into protein,
but I wanna put a pin in that.
Also, I have questions about plant-based milks,
we'll table that for now,
'cause I wanna work through these eight nutrients,
the next being iron.
And correct me if I'm wrong,
but iron works similarly in that it's absorption is impacted
by your vitamin C levels, or taking iron
with vitamin C enhances that absorption.
But maybe before even addressing that,
talk a little bit about the differences
between plant-based iron,
in other words, non-heme iron,
versus animal-based iron, heme iron.
Sure, so there are two different types of iron.
Heme iron is the type of iron you'll find in blood,
and that's why you get it from animal foods.
Animal foods also contained non-heme iron as well.
About 40% of the iron in animal foods is heme
and 60% is non-heme.
And in plants, 100% of the ion is non-heme.
Now broadly speaking, to keep this nice and simple,
the main difference is that heme iron is absorbed
more rapidly than non-heme iron.
And that is because non-heme iron
is often bound to other molecules,
which can slow down and reduce the total absorption.
But that's not necessarily a bad thing.
There is a protective effect of that as well,
because we know that high iron in the body,
and particularly heme iron,
is associated with colorectal cancer
and cardiovascular disease.
So this is, often, I see on social media,
this discussion around well,
heme iron is absorbed more rapidly,
therefore, it must be better.
And I think we just need to acknowledge
that more is not always better.
That's not to say that people eating a plant-based diet
don't need to think about iron.
It's the number one deficiency in the world,
regardless of what diet people are eating.
So this is a real issue.
And so there will always be people that are eating
a plant-based diet that have problems with iron.
It's just part of being human.
Everyone.
Well, not everyone, but a large percentage of the population
are dealing with this.
Even people that are eating meat and dairy products
three times a day are having problems with iron?
There are absolutely still people.
Is there a genetic predisposition
that is problematic with respect to iron absorption?
Or what does that cause by if somebody is eating
plenty of foods that have iron in them?
They could be, but also, you're at higher risk
when you are a female of childbearing age,
and menstruation and losing blood.
And so, it's not all boiling down
to just how much you consume.
And I think that's important to note.
There are at-risk groups, and females of childbearing age
are right up there with the most at-risk.
Is there a genetic component, perhaps,
I'm not, I haven't read anything that speaks to that,
but I wouldn't rule that out.
I mean, a lot of omnivores are dealing with iron deficiency.
And it's also not uncommon for someone
from an omnivorous diet to change
to a plant-based diet and see their iron status go up.
That can happen.
If you, if we look at the population studies, again,
just comparing omnivores to vegetarians,
there is no difference in rates of iron deficiency.
However, vegetarians and vegans do have lower iron stores.
And you will see that when you do your blood tests
and one of the tests looks at iron stores.
So not the iron, the circulating iron,
but how much your body is storing.
And that is typically lower in plant-based eaters,
but is not thought to be a problem as long
as you're topping up your iron through your diet.
I usually like to speak to ways to enhance absorption.
A lot of people listening to this, particularly males,
their iron status will be completely fine,
and they don't really need to focus on this information
I'm about to share, because it is over-complicating things.
So this is more for someone who potentially
has lower iron status and is trying to bump it up a bit.
The foods that are very rich in iron are your legumes,
foods like pumpkin seeds, dark leafy greens.
Chlorella is a great sort of superfood
that's super rich in iron.
And what we wanna focus on is regularly
including these iron-rich foods in the diet,
but pairing them with specific foods
that will enhance absorption and trying to avoid
some foods and drinks that can in inhibit absorption.
So firstly, talking about the inhibitors, coffee and tea.
Yeah, caffeine.
They're the two big ones.
They can decrease the amount of iron you are absorbing.
So if you are sitting down for a big meal
with lots of beans and dark leafy greens,
it might be a good idea to separate that coffee out
at least an hour or so, either side of the meal,
and you will absorb more iron from that meal.
Then there are a few things is you can add to your meals
to enhanced absorption.
The first one and the one that is
the most effective, is sources of vitamin C.
And typically, one that I recommend
for people is lemon juice,
squeezing that over your dark leaf greens
or your stir fry with beans.
But equally, there are other foods like strawberries
that are packed with vitamin C.
So a snack could be dried apricots,
which are super rich in iron, with some strawberries,
and that's a nice match.
Bell pepper, or capsicum, we call it in Australia.
That's another very vitamin C rich food.
So matching these foods in your meals
to enhance iron absorption.
And then the other one that I think's really neat,
and there's some cool science looking at this,
is onion and garlic will both
increase iron absorption significantly.
Oh, I didn't know that one.
So, I usually start any sort of meal, savory meal,
stir fry, or tofu scramble in the pan
with some onion and garlic.
And I think a lot of people do that,
that can be a great strategy as well
to increase the iron absorption.
One of the habits that I adopted a while ago
that I still do today is I keep a bag of pumpkin seeds
in my car with some fruit that's high in vitamin C.
So when I'm driving around, like,
that's like my little go-to snack
and helps me kind of keep things topped off.
You're on the program.
Another habit that I've adopted is eating
a few Brazil nuts every day or every other day,
which are high in selenium, right?
Which is another nutrient on your list.
Why is selenium important?
So selenium feeds back to thyroid, again,
important for production of thyroid hormones.
And as you say, it doesn't require a lot of planning
to hit the selenium recommended intake levels,
which are only about 70, 60, 70 micrograms a day,
not much, one, two Brazil nuts will get you there.
And you're also getting quite a lot of selenium
through wheat.
So whole wheat pasta or bread,
and a lot of other foods like mushrooms.
So you will be getting it elsewhere, elsewhere in your diet,
but the addition of one or two Brazil nuts
will just ensure you're categorically
above that recommended level.
And there's something about the Brazil nut
or the selenium content of the Brazil nut
that has some downstream impact
on testosterone production, right, for dudes?
I haven't read that.
Oh, you haven't.
That's interesting.
Yeah, I think there's, well,
I don't wanna speak outta school 'cause I don't know,
but I'm remembering something about that.
Well, we can look into it.
Yeah, maybe you can look into that.
We'll link something up in the shouts about that.
All right, so selenium is important.
Why?
So back to thyroid it's--
Oh yeah, you already mentioned that.
And metabolism, I mean,
it has a whole lot of different functions
in the body, but the, it is integral again,
to thyroid health, which is integral to your metabolism
and management of your body weight.
So, I don't think we really need
to go into too much more than that in terms of
the biological sort of pathways,
but the main point being it's super easy
to get in your diet, although it's
in this list of eight nutrients of focus,
rarely would a plant-based eater not get enough selenium.
I just like talking about it
because it's a nice one to point to Brazil nuts
as a single food that people can look to
to ensure adequate intake.
Okay, final thing on your list of eight nutrients is zinc.
We're hearing a lot about zinc lately.
We're being told that we should be making sure
that we're on top of our zinc for COVID purposes.
So I assume without knowing, that there's some link
between zinc and immune system function.
Definitely, very important for immunity, for hair,
skin, nail health, for energy production,
preventing DNA damage.
It's a crucial mineral,
and you're going to find it mostly in nuts and legumes,
a kind of like the, and seeds, and hemp seeds,
for example, packed with zinc, but cashews,
another great one, pretty easy to get.
As long as you are regularly eating nuts
and seeds, and legumes,
which anyone who is adopting a whole food plant-based diet
will be, you'll have no problems reaching
the sort of adequate intake for that.
Right.
I think that's a good place to pivot
to a different category here.
At the outset, we kind of opened this with a discussion
about how to optimize your plant-based diet
and the idea that just because you're eating vegan,
doesn't necessarily mean that it's healthy,
there's all kinds of meat and dairy analogs out there.
Some of them moderately healthy, some very much not healthy.
So on that note,
let's talk a little bit about these analogs.
When we think about what's available now,
the Beyond Meats and the Impossibles,
are these products healthy?
Do they have a place in a healthy, optimal plant-based diet?
I think they certainly have a place,
no word about it,
but there are some that are healthier than others.
So it's nice to be able to be able to read the label
and quickly scan to see a few different things
and make a healthier decision.
And what are the things that we should be looking at
when we look at that label?
So I usually focus on sodium, on fiber and saturated fat,
and I'm looking for a product that has 400 milligrams
or less sodium per serve,
ideally around five grams of fiber per serve.
That is not always achievable.
That narrows the field a lot.
Yeah, that pretty much eliminates
almost everything in the category.
Yeah, well, not quite, but it will,
it'll really point you in the right direction.
And then saturated fat.
Look, this really depends on the person.
If you are someone who has healthy cholesterol levels,
and we kind of spoke about what optimal cholesterol levels
are previously, which is South
of 100 milligrams per deciliter.
And as you get down to 60 to 70,
that's where you see no atherosclerosis.
If you are sitting down at that sort of level,
you can afford to have a bit more saturated fat
in your diet.
And so when I'm working with people,
I encourage someone who has higher cholesterol
to be looking for the lower saturated fat options.
These are the ones that have two grams
or less saturated fat per serve.
But if your cholesterol is at an optimal level,
then I really see no problem with the four
or five grams of saturated fat per serve
within the context of a healthy plant-based dietary pattern.
And that seems to be pretty typical, a lot of them sit
at around three grams of saturated fat, four or five.
I certainly wouldn't be,
routinely selecting the ones
that have North of five grams of saturated fat per serve.
What about the binders and the emulsifiers,
and all these other ingredients that go into
creating that texture that people like?
So my answer to that would be, we need more data.
And I'm not saying that these are necessarily bad,
or they're not.
There just, hasn't been a lot of studies
on some of this, these ingredients.
And, there was a study that came out last week
on carboxymethyl cellulose, which is a common emulsifier.
And I spoke to Tim Specter, who's a professor
from King's College about this, and it was
a short term study, but these studies should say, Rich,
they're just starting to surface, looking at
how these ingredients interact with our microbiome,
for example.
And they did see disruption in this study to the microbiome,
with the consumption of this emulsifier.
However, it was 15 grams a day.
And if you are consuming one plant-based burger
that has, probably half a gram, a bit maximum in there,
then perhaps it doesn't have the same effect.
So in the absence of the data,
I'm kind of reserving my judgment
on a lot of those ingredients.
What I will say is there has been a study
outta Stanford University called the "SWAP-MEAT Trial."
And I think this is quite instructive
because it really, it takes a very well-known
plant-based meat product, Beyond Burger,
and stacks it up directly against meat products.
And they chose high-quality organic meat products
to make sure that this was a good study, fair.
And I think this is instructive because it looked more
at our overall risk factors for cardiovascular disease,
which is the leading cause of death.
Having a heart attack is the most likely reason
that you or I are to die, that's just fact.
And they had these subjects come in and do,
an eight-week randomized controlled trial crossover.
So you had a period where you ate the animal,
the animal meat products,
and then you had a period where you ate
the plant-based meats supplied by Beyond.
So every participant did both.
Every participant did both
and they did them in different orders.
And they were most interested in blood pressure,
LDL cholesterol, and also a biomarker
of cardiovascular disease called TMAO.
And they instructed participants to consume two serves
of these meat products per day.
So that was the kind of volume that they were exposed to.
And they did see over the course of this study,
that when subjects were consuming the plant-based meats,
they had significant reductions in TMAO,
they had significant reductions in LDL cholesterol.
And when, I wanna remind people,
this is not comparing against
the unhealthiest meats out there,
it was literally from an organic butcher in San Francisco,
and these were 80% lean beef products.
So it wasn't set up to make the beef fail.
And then blood pressure, they saw no significant difference.
And that was important because
a lot of these plant-based meat products
are often very rich in sodium, which I mentioned before.
So, I mean, the findings from that study are promising,
it's one study, it's early days,
but based on the nutritional profile of these products,
particularly if you're selecting them according
to how I kind of walk through,
and the results of that study,
I have no problem with these featuring within
a whole food plant-based dietary pattern.
I certainly don't think they should be the main stake
every single meal, because then they're coming
at the expense of legumes and tempeh,
and you beans, lentils, tempeh, tofu,
foods that we know absolutely are great
for driving down disease risk.
Yeah, you're gonna get no argument from me that
the program really should be pre-dominated by whole foods.
Plant-based, close to their natural state.
The question was really like,
if you have one of these every once in a while,
what is the impact of that?
And I think one of the reasons that I bring it up is there's
a narrative, particularly amongst sort of the paleo crowd,
like these are all science experiments.
They're terrible.
There are GMOs in a lot of these products,
and there are these emulsifiers and all these other things,
these binders that go into creating these products.
So yes, a whole food is going to always be better,
but how bad are they truly, like,
what is a trumped up narrative versus the truth?
And what I gather from what you're saying is we're just
at the beginning of studying this,
the Stanford University study seems to be interesting
in that when balanced,
at least against a typical burger, an organic burger,
it's still gonna measure out better
in terms of those main markers.
Compared to what, is like the critical question here.
If people are adding these into their diet
and it's knocking out the enormous amounts
of animal protein, I think it's definitely shifting
their overall health profile in the right direction.
And I'm also mindful of the fact that consistency
over time is far more important than
how healthy every single food or every single meal is.
And some of these foods make it easier
for people to sustain an otherwise whole food,
plant-based dietary pattern for longer.
Some of that can be down to social circumstances,
many different factors.
So my sort of view of them is
I certainly wouldn't want to vilify them,
I think they serve a role.
With that said, I would love more
and more studies to be done on them.
And I think that we should hold these companies accountable.
So that as more data comes out
and we understand more, they are reformulating,
and continuing to improve their product
to make it not just delicious
and a great alternative to meat, but healthier as well.
Yeah, particularly the more ubiquitous they become
and the more they find their way into kind of our fast food
and fast casual infrastructure,
because so many people are eating them.
So there is an accountability thing
that I think is important here.
And my hope is that as these things continue
to scale, that we're also seeing the on-ramping
of healthier versions of all of these things.
And I'm already seeing that.
Like I just was in Vancouver
at this big plant-based expo,
and there must have been 200 exhibitors there,
there's so many food companies
that are doing interesting things,
and to see what people are doing with mushrooms
and all these like ingredients that you never
would've thought would comprise like the architecture of
a plant-based food, but doing it with natural ingredients.
And I think that's pretty exciting.
Yeah, I love the,
there's some really great mushroom products coming out.
There's a few of those in Australia and I'm very optimistic.
For example, there is a company in Australia called BUDS.
And I like the fact that they're Australian,
because there's not a whole lot of kind of big players
in this space that are, so I'm kind of rooting for them.
But I say that because they have contacted me
and I've spoken to them about
the nutritional profile of their product.
So I do genuinely think that these companies are aware
that they need to not only be an alternative,
they do need to be healthier.
And a great example of that is back to Beyond Meat.
They just released, I think two new burgers.
One is I think about 50% reduced saturated fat,
and the other is 30% reduced saturated fat,
and these are iterations for them.
So, that change, that that will happen.
And the key message being,
they probably shouldn't be the absolute mainstay
of your diet, but their inclusion can make
a diet more enjoyable for certain people.
And let's also keep in mind that compared
to the products they're displacing,
they're much better the environment
from a land use point-of-view,
from a water preservation point-of-view,
from a greenhouse gas and meeting point-of-view.
And at the same time, they're kinder
to all life on the planet.
Yeah, 100%.
But it's also compared to what situation as well,
because most of them are not organic,
and they rely on monocropping for their supply chain.
So there's a whole other like layer
or level of creating these things
in a more sustainable healthy way.
I think that's part of holding them accountable.
Very much at the moment,
they kind of seem to be from my understanding
and speaking to certain people,
is that they're piggybacking off of a lot of
the sort of monocrops that are grown,
that are fed into the animal agriculture industry.
But what certainly, what I'd like to see going forward
is these companies supporting regenerative agriculture,
and not just using monocropped ingredients,
thinking about polycropping,
and that's just another component
of holding them accountable.
And most of them are pledging
that they are pro-planetary health.
So, I'm optimistic.
Well, of course, that's the whole reason
for their existence.
But I think the real value ad proposition here is
that it's transitioning other people
who are otherwise not considering going plant-based at all,
into a more plant-oriented diet
and getting them off these animal products.
So it's, again, it goes back to the comparison
against what are you comparing these things to.
And part of that transition period,
it can be difficult to acclimatize to more fiber.
And so that's where some of these products
can be really helpful.
And I actually recommend them to a number of people
that are going through the steps of trying
to reduce animal products in their diet.
And perhaps they're finding the sudden increase
in legumes to be a little bit like an atomic bomb.
And that is one way of helping back off
the fiber a little bit
and make that process more comfortable.
Well, let's talk about that for a minute
because that's another thing that I hear a lot,
I'm sure you do as well.
I tried a plant-based diet and the beans
and the legumes and all of that,
I just was so bloated and gassy,
and I just couldn't hang with it.
It's a process.
And we spoke about that other,
the fermented food fiber study last time,
which I think illustrated that the addition of fiber
to the diet will have varying effects on people
depending on where their baseline microbiome is.
So if someone has a more severely disrupted microbiome,
perhaps they had a lot of antibiotics growing up,
and have been eating a very high ultra-processed food diet
that we know is disruptive.
They may struggle a little more
with increasing their fiber intake very rapidly.
So going slow and low is from my experience
by far the best strategy, rather than an over the night,
changing from the average intake of fiber is
about 12 to 15 grams in Australia and America.
Going from that to North of 30,
40 grams is going to really shock your system.
So I usually work on ramping it up with people,
starting with small increments, for example,
a quarter of a cup of cooked lentils is
about out four grams of fiber.
And that's how much I'll get people
to modulate their diet by every day, second day.
And to step through these changes
over two, three, four months,
rather than trying to do it all in one week.
On the topic of legumes,
a game changer that I've personally felt and used,
and also something that I know has helped
a lot of other people,
is pressure cookers, an instant pot.
Have you heard of that?
Mm hm, yeah, we have one.
Yeah, so, I mean, if you're buying dried beans,
they need to be soaked and then cooked,
that can be a very drawn-out, long process,
and some people don't have the time to do that.
And a pressure cooker is a much faster way of doing it.
You still can soak them beforehand,
but soaking doesn't take up a lot of your own time,
and it is optional, but the pressure cooker
will essentially, you'll have your beans
or legumes ready in an hour,
hour and a half, depending on the type.
And certainly makes them a lot more digestible.
And you can add into there some ginger or kombu,
which is a type of seaweed,
which I haven't found a whole lot of good data on,
but anecdotally does seem to be helping people digest them.
And so that's one strategy
that I do recommend is making sure
you're preparing your legumes properly.
And in doing that, you'll reduce some of
the fermentable carbohydrates,
the sort of gas-producing carbohydrates and thus,
they'll be a little bit easier to tolerate.
If you're buying canned beans,
you can also reduce some of those gas-producing molecules
by rinsing them very thoroughly
under water before you eat them.
But ostensibly, what you're saying is
in terms of this acclimation period,
it's really a period of time in which your microbiome has
to adjust to this different type of food.
And by eating it, you're kind of seeding your gut lining
with the prebiotic, the biota, ostensibly, that you need
to create this new flora that then can digest these foods
without the bloating and the gassiness.
Yeah, and so exactly, it's a little bit like fertilizer,
you're sprinkling this fertilizer over
the microbes and they will proliferate,
and the microbes that are fermenting
these carbohydrates will grow in numbers.
And so your gut, put simply, will grow stronger.
Similar to going into the gym,
picking up a weight, and progressively increasing
that weight, your muscle will grow stronger.
And the downstream effect of doing that is creating
a more diverse microbiome, which produces more
of those wonderful short chain fatty acids,
which help maintain the integrity of that mucosal layer
and the epithelial cells that line
the large intestine, and helps reduce inflammation
and improve blood glucose control.
All those things we spoke about, previously.
Right, the diversity of plant foods contributes
to a more diverse microbiome, which makes you more robust.
The analogy being when you go to the gym,
you do all different kinds of,
as many different types of exercises as possible
to become as bulletproof as possible.
Yeah, and I've kind of oversimplified it
a little bit there, there is more going on
in terms of the microbiota composition.
We are just learning now about polyphenols,
how they affect the microbiome.
I like how excited you get.
Every time you say polyphenols,
you get this big smile on your face.
Like, the only person who smiles more broadly
with that word is Dr. B, I think.
Yeah, and ironically,
we've had some great chats about them, but,
I say that because like black beans for example,
are very rich in polyphenols.
And so it's not just fiber that is modulating
the microbiome, but also these polyphenols, which,
just five, 10 years ago,
we thought were all absorbed in the small intestine.
Most of them are traveling through to the large intestine
where they are directly affecting the microbiota,
where they're acting as another form of prebiotic.
They fall under the same banner
as prebiotic fiber and resistance starch.
And they provoke an increase in the proliferation
of these short chain fatty acid-producing bacteria.
And there was a recent study that came out,
which took older people.
These were people that were aged about 66 years of age
and did a randomized controlled trial, and very neat design,
because they held the fiber the same,
but just increased polyphenols in one arm.
And they saw that the group who added these polyphenols,
and that was largely from like green tea
and pomegranate, and some cacao,
these are all very polyphenol-rich foods.
They had decreased levels of vazaulin,
which is a marker of intestinal permeability, or,
quote unquote, "leaky gut."
So, you know.
So for somebody who suffers
from some kind of ulcerative colitis
or autoimmune gut-related disorder,
amping up your polyphenols might be a good idea.
Yeah, and the idea here,
and this is very, very preliminary,
but there are some theories out there,
that where someone is not tolerating the fiber,
the increase in fiber so much,
it might be a good strategy to increase polyphenols first.
And from some of these foods where they're incredibly rich
in polyphenols, but quite low in fiber,
like green tea, for example,
as a way to encourage microbiome diversity,
similar to what we spoke about with the fermented foods.
Right, so you're increasing,
or you're decreasing gut permeability prior
to sort of ramping up the fiber,
which might cause some distress if you have
a permeability issue.
Yeah, and that's a, that's something that an experiment,
no doubt will test.
And I think the Sonnenburgs at Stanford
are doing something similar.
So we'll know more about that, but in theory,
from a mechanistic point-of-view, it does make sense.
Yeah, I gotta get those Sonnenburgs on the podcast.
Have you spoken to them? We talked about that, didn't we?
I think we talked about last time.
Well, actually only spoke to Justin
about four days ago for the first time.
I spoken many times to Chris Gardner,
but yeah, you should get them.
Chris Gardner's the one who did
the Beyond versus organic beef study, right?
And he comes up with all these acronyms,
like the "SWAP-MEAT Trial," and like DIETFITS.
And he's a laugh, but yeah,
the Sonnenburgs, both Justin and Erica,
are like the wizards when it comes to the microbiome.
So certainly, yeah, you should get them on.
I hear everything you're saying,
but Simon, with respect to beans at least,
Dr. Gundry told me I gotta worry about these lectins.
Well, this comes back to understanding exposure level.
When we consider whether a food
or a nutrient is healthy or harmful.
And an analogy here that I'll use is oxygen.
If I gave you pure oxygen, 100% oxygen,
you would pass out and eventually die.
But I'm sure that you would agree with me
that oxygen is healthy and it's life sustaining,
and we need it.
It's in our air, right?
Oxygen in air is at 26%, I believe is the concentration.
And at that level, it is very healthy.
The dose makes the poison, and this is similar with lectins.
We could cherry-pick and look at some mechanistic studies,
animal studies, where they're exposed
to very, very high, extremely high levels of lectins
that you would never be exposed to in your diet.
And we could show some impairment of the microbiome
or the intestinal barrier and leaky gut.
However, if we zoom back out
and look at all of the data on people consuming legumes,
observational data shows that there are the hallmark of
the diets of the people who live the longest,
and then we see experimentally
in randomized controlled trials,
that the addition of these foods
help improve biomarkers of disease,
like cholesterol, for example.
So the dose really makes the poison.
Beans do contain lectins, that's true,
and it's why I wouldn't recommend eating dried beans.
But nobody eats dried beans.
Nobody does, except there is one study where,
and this is cited, where patients,
if I recall correctly, in Japan, were accidentally
fed raw, improperly prepared legumes,
and they had an acute reaction response to it.
And certainly I just wouldn't recommend doing it.
It's why we soak.
It's why we use a pressure cooker.
It reduces lectins and they're still there,
but they're reduced to a level where they're actually
thought to be very beneficial.
And this is the sort of ironic thing.
And you could run a search and look at this online.
There are just as many mechanistic studies
showing benefits of lectins and that lectins
actually have anticarcinogenic properties.
So why does Gundry have such a bee
in his bonnet over this?
Well, I think that he's over-extrapolating
from these studies in animals where they are exposed
to enormous amount of lectins.
I haven't seen any good evidence to suggest
that we should be worried about lectins
in properly prepared legumes.
And very, very consistently,
legumes are shown to improve health.
They're arguably one of the healthiest foods
out there on planet Earth.
So, it's an absolute message and it helps sell a book.
I'm not sure what else I can say.
Yeah, I mean, it is the consistent theme
across all the blue zones.
And Dan Bruner is always talking about beans
being really the centerpiece of a healthy diet.
So I think we can put to rest the lectin fear.
And then with that said,
still acknowledge that when you are adding legumes
to your diet and you haven't had them in your diet,
that it's going to take some time for your microbiome
to adjust, go low, go slow,
use some of those strategies that we spoke about,
and you will absolutely get there.
Right, you're gonna fart
and you're gonna burp a little bit,
but it'll be fine.
It'll be a bumpy ride, but it'll be worth it.
So Simon, animal protein versus plant protein.
Perhaps the number one concern for most people
who are considering a plant-based diet.
Hmm, let's break this down to basics first.
Protein, what is it?
It's amino acids.
And they're building blocks of all of
the 30,000-odd proteins in body.
And there are 11 non-essential amino acids.
Those are amino acids
our body can produce endogenously.
And then there are nine essential amino acids,
which our body cannot produce,
and therefore, it's critical that we are getting them
in our diet in some way, shape, or form,
in the required amounts.
We covered previously, that there is a myth
that plant-based foods are missing essential amino acids.
And that's not true.
All plants do contain all nine essential amino acids.
So it's not as if when you are removing animal foods
and you're going to plant foods
that there is absence of any of these building blocks
that you cannot get, and therefore,
your body would have trouble building protein.
That's not the case.
Second thing that I think is important for all of us
to understand, and sometimes I overlook this
in my explanations, is our food contains protein,
whether it's chicken or whether it's beans,
or whether it's tofu, whatever it may be.
And when we digest that,
we break that protein down into amino acids
and amino acids are absorbed into the bloodstream.
And then once they're in our bloodstream,
they're not tagged, our body has no idea
if that was a leucine molecule from chicken,
or if it was from soy.
Once they're in the bloodstream,
they are just available amino acids for our body
to use as as it needs to, to produce protein.
So with all of that said,
then it becomes clear that we just to get enough
of those nine essential amino acids into our bloodstream
and our body will do the rest of the work.
The bloodstream transports them where they need to go
and when they arrive at their destination,
they're the building blocks to be assembled
into whatever the body needs in that specific location.
Exactly.
And I don't wanna cover, retrace too much territory,
but the only way that you would run into problem on
a plant-based diet in terms of supplying adequate amounts
of each of those nine essential amino acids,
is if you were severely under-eating
and getting nowhere near the total number of calories
that you require, or, and/or,
living off of one or two foods,
as you can often see in certain parts of the world
where there are food security issues.
And that's a whole nother situation.
So if you're super deficient in one of
the nine essential amino acids,
then your body can't actually rebuild those proteins
that it needs, and you're gonna run into problems.
Exactly, it becomes a limiting amino acid,
and then it affects protein synthesis.
And of course, we want to avoid that.
If you are eating with diversity and you're paying attention
to regularly consuming the protein-rich plant foods,
which I like to point out that most of
the protein is coming from the legume food group,
also quite a bit from nuts and seeds.
So if you are including regularly the likes of beans,
lentils, chickpeas, tofu, tempeh, legume pastas,
even seitan or total TVP, these are all very,
very protein-rich foods.
And as long as you're including them in your diet,
and I like to recommend people have
at least three serves of those a day,
a serve being about half a cup of beans
or half a cup of tofu, or a cup of soy milk,
that's another good, very protein-rich serve.
If as long as you are getting three of those
in a day across the diet, then you will be consuming
these essential amino acid in the required amounts.
Of course, if you're an athlete,
then you're gonna wanna pay even more attention
to leaning into that food group.
And you might consider a protein supplement,
which is something that all athletes consider,
whether they consume an omnivorous diet
or a plant-based diet.
And then there is also so a strong case to be made,
and I was recently speaking with Ginny Messina,
who's a very well-known registered dietician,
in the sort of plant-based community.
And we were talking about,
there is a very compelling case for paying
a little more attention to protein
as you get over the age of 50.
And some of that, again,
feeds back to our earlier conversation
around bone mineral density and lean muscle.
We know that having more lean muscle
as you get older is associated with longevity.
So, overall, as you get above 50,
I like people to lean a little more
into legumes, and to make room for that.
Not excluding them, but a little less
into whole grains and potatoes, and starches.
And that allows them to sort of slightly bump up
that protein intake.
And I think you've had Valter Longo
on here a a couple of times, and he's also an advocate
of that strategy, to just bump that protein up a little bit
to actually help increase lifespan and health outcomes.
So to play devil's advocate,
what is your response to the statement
that animal protein is just superior?
Like, is there a foundation for that argument
or what else goes into animal protein
that would provide that person
with some logical basis for making that statement?
What is superior, right?
Well, let's do that.
If we were, if you were saying to me, building lean muscle
is it easier to build lean muscle with
a diet full of animal products than plant-based products
with less consideration and planning?
Yes, it is.
I mean, we have to be able to acknowledge that.
That's not saying you can't get the same result,
you can, but you have to plan a little more
on the plant-based side of things.
But my definition of superior is I want be fit
and I wanna build muscle, but at the same time
I want consider my long-term health outcomes,
and I want to consider longevity.
And we have to understand that there's a trade off here.
One of the big differences is the ratio
and concentration of particular amino acids
between animal and plant foods.
And while animal foods might be very rich
in certain amino acids that activate mTOR
for example, and raise IGF-1 levels,
and while that might be great for promoting growth,
we understand through a lot of mechanistic research,
and I will preface this by saying most of this is
in animal models because it cannot be done in humans.
At least not at this stage.
We understand that over-activating those,
works against you in terms of your longevity.
So, this is not a sort of simple answer
or simple question of what's superior.
It's really, what's meaningful to you.
And, personally, I made the decision
that I want to be consuming foods that are allowing me
to achieve my athletic endeavors,
pursue those goals, but at the same time,
not over activate mTOR to the point that I'm putting myself
at higher risk of certain diseases
and potentially shortening my overall lifespan.
So if you're 24 years old and all you care
about is how you're gonna perform in four months
at the championships or what have you,
and you don't care about anything else,
all you want to do is ramp up that IGF-1
and get as much strength and growth as conceivable
in a short period of time.
But that's at the cost of longevity, longterm health,
all these things that are important
in terms of maintaining vitality, fitness, strength,
all of those things over the extension of your lifetime.
And even as a kind of a plant-based person,
you can still modulate your diet
to promote muscle growth and strength.
And I spoke to one of the studies that looked
at comparing healthy young adults,
omnivorous diet versus a vegan diet,
and they matched that total protein intake
at about 1.6, 1.7 grams per kilo,
which is a high protein intake.
And they saw no differences in lean muscle and strength.
That's really important point to make.
So I think that there is a way to kind of have both.
And so you can shift to a plant-based diet
and then modify it in a way where you are getting
the performance gains that you are looking for.
And I still think you are better off, better protected
than the animal-based diet.
Are you potentially making a trade off compared
to a slightly lower protein plant-based diet?
I think, possibly.
And that's based on those mechanistic animal studies,
but back to your earlier point, people have different goals.
And for some people, it will be meaningful
to build muscle and to build strength
while adopting this dietary pattern
that is overall better for their chronic disease,
better for the planet, and better for the animals.
In addition, if we're gonna contemplate
like quote unquote "gains,"
you also have to consider all of these other things,
like inflammation and foods that you're are eating
that are gonna allow your body to recover more quickly.
And if you're eating a predominantly plant-based diet,
chances are, it's gonna be more anti-inflammatory
than an animal-based or animal-centric diet,
which is gonna allow your body to recover more quickly.
So that has to go into that equation as well.
And I think there is something in that
that we haven't yet determined from science,
but there's a lot of anecdotal evidence
from athletes toward the end of their careers
who are shifting towards more plant-based.
And really cool, and I wish I had details to share,
and it'll sound like I'm obsessed with Stanford,
but hey, they're doing great research.
I'm obsessed with Stanford.
I'm biased, but...
And I noticed you're wearing an SF hat, you know?
So last time you were wearing an LA hat.
That's sort of going back to a funny story,
one of your listeners sent me this hat.
Oh, really?
So I think they wanted me.
They they're from San Francisco, Patrick, actually.
So thank you, Patrick.
I obviously wear the LA one too much.
I love hats, but back to Stanford, again,
Professor Christopher Gardner and his group,
they are about to run for the first time.
And this is with athletes at Stanford.
They didn't get access to the real high level athletes.
The coaches didn't want them
to be play around with their diets,
but they still got athletes from Stanford University
and they will be doing a randomized controlled trial of
a completely plant-based versus an omnivorous diet,
looking at strength and endurance over the longterm.
Interesting, interesting.
Any of the swimmers doing on that?
I might have to make a phone call or two.
I'd love to know more about that.
Super interesting.
Shifting gears a little bit, one of the things
that we're cautioned against with respect
to animal products, particularly processed beets,
is nitrates, right?
Nitrates, carcinogenic,
but here we have greens that have nitrates
and those are good nitrates?
What's going on?
Isn't that confusing?
Yeah, it is.
So, it's like biweekly.
Does it mean once every two weeks or twice a week?
Yeah, I don't know.
Don't test me on those kind of things.
Go ahead.
So I guess the first thing is
that nitrates are a wonderful supplement
and we can go into that from
a performance point-of-view.
There's some good data on that,
but from a food point-of-view,
we have nitrates in ultra-processed meats, as you said,
and then there's nitrates that are
in dark leafy greens, beetroot, and celery.
And how can these molecules, the same molecule,
have a different effect on our physiology
and our health outcomes?
It has a lot to do with the food matrix
and what those nitrates are packaged next to.
So we know that in ultra-processed foods,
the nitrates, they're often used as a preservative.
That's why they're in like cured meats.
We know that when you consume those,
the pathway they go down is one that ends up resulting
in the production of N nitroso compounds.
And a lot of that is thought to be due
to the fact that they're packaged, the nitrates
are packaged next to amines and heme iron,
which is thought to be
what preferentially shoots them down this pathway.
And these, the N nitroso compounds can damage DNA
in the gut, and are thought to be probably carcinogenic.
So that's that pathway.
And then the nitrates in dark leafy greens,
and beetroot, these foods that are associated
with great health outcomes and time and time again,
we really see we should be leaning into more of,
they're packaged next to polyphenols and vitamin C.
And it, the evidence so far shows that the,
because of that, they're reduced from nitrates
to nitrites, and then nitrites to nitric oxide.
And we know that nitric oxide is very beneficial
from an endothelial cell function,
improving the function of your arteries,
blood flow, driving down inflammation.
It's like an endurance booster.
Yeah, and that's why there's a whole lot of supplements
out there via different pathways
we can go into, that boost nitric oxide,
and nitrates being one of those.
So the take on point is that
there is sort of two different pathways
and their fate is determined by how,
what is packaged next to that nitrate?
There's an interesting study that I looked at
which dug into the oral microbiome.
The microbiome is not just in the colon,
we have lots of bacteria in the oral cavity,
and it does seem, that first step I said there,
from dark leafy grains and beetroot
where nitrates goes to nitrites,
which is absolutely required
in order to get to nitric oxide.
That first step starts in the mouth, and--
With the saliva?
With whatever's in the saliva, breaking it down.
There's bacteria on the dorsal side,
the top side of the tongue, that seems to start
that reduction, and very interestingly,
a set of researchers thought,
well, what about if we give,
do a randomized controlled trial
and have some subjects consume a mouthwash
with an antimicrobial?
And they saw that these subjects
who were using the mouthwash and it was over about,
there's a few studies now, three day and a seven day,
but quite quickly they saw that these subjects
had less nitric oxide production and higher blood pressure.
I don't know whether we should read too much into that,
but it's an interesting fact, probably more so
for someone with hypertension, that is
thinking about all of the different tools and levers
they can pull to lower their blood pressure,
which nitrates will do.
But if you are using this mouthwash and it contained
an antimicrobial called chlorhexidine,
which is quite common, that might impair
the conversion to nitric oxide.
It can't be a good idea to take an antimicrobial mouthwash
and kill the microbiome that exists in your mouth.
I agree, it's kind of like taking antibiotics.
I think we're just starting to learn
about the importance of the oral microbiome.
So yeah, I would agree.
It doesn't make a whole lot of sense.
There might be a few dentists out there listening
who don't like to hear that.
So I'm sure there's two sides to that conversation,
but for what it's worth, that's what the study found.
Right, yeah.
It's interesting.
I mean, obviously you don't want bad breath
and if you have an infection or something like that
in your mouth, you want to clean that out,
but you would want something that was targeted
as opposed to just destroying all the life forms
that exist symbiotically in your mouth
and perform a healthy function for you.
Yeah, I suspect that that's probably
the answer here, is that maybe these have
some utility in certain circumstances,
but maybe they're not just kind of everyday thing
that you want to be using all the time.
And really just killing off these microbes,
many of which have very beneficial effects.
So nitrites, nitrate oxide, a good source of
that is beets, athletes know this.
Lettuce.
Lettuce, also?
Dark leafy greens.
Well, that's not such a dark leafy green,
it depends on what kind of lettuce I suppose.
Lettuce has more nitrates than spinach.
Very, very, I was surprised by that.
But just your average, like iceberg lettuce?
It's a good question.
I'd have to dig into the study and see.
They just really said lettuce, but you're right,
there are different types.
So perhaps I can put that on my list of things
to go and look at.
But nonetheless, the dark leaf greens
are really rich in nitrates.
So is celery, beetroots are like the superstar.
and now you see--
Is that the active ingredient in beetroot
or are there other things in beetroot
that make it such an effective endurance booster?
That is certainly the main active compound
and the reason why you're seeing athletes all
across the world consume beetroot powder.
It's very effective.
Like if I am going out for a long workout,
I can feel the difference from when I put beets
and be beet greens into my smoothie beforehand,
versus when I don't.
Like it's noticeable.
So the science looking at this has shown
that these nitrates in beetroot, essentially reduce
the amount of oxygen that your body requires
to produce the same amount of work.
So you are more efficient.
Which is like, yeah, it's like going from altitude
down to sea level.
Yes, so you can do the same amount of muscular work
for longer, or you can do increased muscular work
for the same period of time.
And this is one that, I've recommended this
to many athletes and across the board,
everyone seems to have great results with it,
but dosing is important and the timing
are two very important things.
So talk about that.
I don't know anything about that.
I just dump a bunch of beets in my smoothie
and go out the door.
Yeah, and you're probably doing it perfectly right.
The timing you could probably do a little better.
It seems that maximum effect is about two,
two and a half hours before your exercise.
Oh, wow.
Now that can
be challenging if you are someone
who wakes up and exercises first thing.
So it's obviously, it needs to work in with
how you're doing it, and what your schedule is, sorry.
But that does seem to be maximum effect,
two and a half to three hours prior.
And in terms of the dosage, so people will see,
depending on the brand they're looking at it,
it could show up as millimoles,
or it could show up as grams.
I'm gonna speak in grams because it's
a little bit more common and there is a conversion.
So one millimole is 62 grams of nitrates
if you want to convert back.
But consistently the science shows you need
about 530 grams of nitrates to get maximum effect.
There is some effect occurring at about 300.
So there's this 300 to five sort of 30 range grams
of nitrates with the best sort
of ergogenic effect, performance-enhancing benefit,
occurring at 530 grams.
Once you go above that,
it doesn't seem like there's any extra benefit.
And I will say the more aerobically fit the athlete,
the smaller the benefit they get.
So this is all about increasing your efficiency,
but if you're already a very efficient person, athlete,
then the gains are a little bit lower.
But the more elite and efficient you are,
the less gains you need to differentiate yourself
from everybody else, right?
Like a 1% increase versus a 5% increase.
When you're at the elite level, I mean, 1% is huge.
Sure.
And also arguably those are the people
that should be focusing on this sort of stuff the most,
because they've got all the basic foundations, right?
And the basic foundations of dietary pattern
and sleep, and stuff, are so much more important
than what we're talking about here.
These are kind of like the very, very top.
Yeah, it's the cherry on the top.
It's the cherry on the top?
The plant-based Sunday.
Yeah.
So, I mean, that's kind of the current thinking
in terms of--
So that sort of dosage, sorry to interrupt,
but like that gram amount, 530, what did you say?
530 grams.
So translate that into like how--
Sorry, 530 milligrams.
Milligrams?
Let me clarify.
Yeah, you said grams before was, sounded by,
so a millimole--
One millimole is 62 milligrams.
Okay, that's a big difference.
I wanna really clarify that.
And so you're targeting 300 to 530 milligrams.
Okay, that's not very much.
So how much would be in a typical beet?
So to hit that 530 milligrams,
I've calculated at three and a half medium size beetroots.
Beetroot, that's an Australian thing.
So the, when you say beetroot,
that means the beet with the greens on top of it.
Just the beet.
Or just the beet.
And what is the, like, I always put,
when I'm making a smoothie, I take the greens.
You go to the grocery store, they rip the greens off,
and they want to toss 'em away.
But I love the greens and I put those
in the smoothie as well or I cook them.
Yeah, they'll will contain nitrates as well.
But at a lesser.
Yeah, the study that I saw that looked
at nitrate content was just looking at the beet.
Got it.
Which was, and I calculated,
you would need three and a half medium-sized beets
to get to that 530.
That's a lot.
And that's probably why the powders have become so popular.
And so you just need to find one that has,
is supplying 530 milligrams.
And I think we should probably also make it clear here
that with all of these supplements, nitrates included,
if you are a professional athlete,
you need to be working with your club dietician.
They will be considering what brands you can and cannot buy.
Often, you need to buy brands that have gone
through specific testing.
And there has been issues where what's in,
what the ingredient label says is
in the product is not actually what's in there.
So you kind of, if you're going
to add these things into your regime
and your professional athletes,
sit down with the right people.
Is there any thoughts around usage in terms of cycling?
Like, is this something that you could do every day?
And it's just like, if you're training really hard,
should you use it daily or should you use it
for a period of time, get off it, go back on it?
I'm not sure there is enough data to say
what is the best option there.
So far, the data is suggesting that it's completely safe
to take that on a daily basis,
but whether coming on and off is a more effective strategy
and leads to greater efficiency longterm,
I don't think that's been teased out.
Are there, I want to kind of slide
into a conversation about supplements
for athletes more broadly, but on the subject
of beetroot and nitrates, and nitrites,
is there a supplement,
like why not go right directly to the nitrous oxide?
Like, can you, is there a supplement
where you could just, in capsule form,
take nitrous oxide and achieve the effect
that the beetroot active ingredient is producing?
I don't think it's that easy.
From my read, is if you want to actually absorb it
and increase nitric oxide levels in the body,
you have to deliver one of the precursors.
And that is either nitrates or the other one
that you will see is L Citrulline.
And L Citrulline is another supplement
that will boost nitric oxide in the body.
It does it by raising arginine levels,
which then a converted by a completely different pathway
to what we've spoken about.
It's an endogenous pathway way to nitric oxide.
So as far as I'm aware, you need to provide a precursor.
And that has to be in the form of nitrates or L Citrulline.
My preference of the two is nitrates,
because there's been more study on them.
Got it.
I'm just gonna eat my beets.
Am I good with that?
That's what I do.
All right.
For what it's worth.
Supplements for athletes.
At the top of this pyramid, obviously protein powders.
So let's talk about that.
Like, do we need to be taking protein powders?
How much, is this advisable?
When should we take it?
And which types of plant protein extracts are optimal?
And there's a lot in that question.
It's a lot there.
It's going to be context-dependent.
I will say, I think most athletes certainly
that I work with or spoken to, find a protein powder
a very convenient way to get 30 grams of protein in.
And it's also a little less filling
than always eating legumes.
So I think it certainly has utility,
but I will say that you can still build muscle
and perform very well without it.
Yeah, I had Robert Cheeke here
and he was talking about his history
with this going from, and mine is similar,
like having a pantry full of all kinds of powders,
then thinking like,
is this doing anything and weaning himself off of it,
and realizing that without any of it,
he was making gains that he wasn't capable of prior.
And his point being like, maybe they have use,
but they shouldn't come at the cost
of sourcing your nutrients from whole foods.
And if you're meeting those needs,
is there any advantage at all to even doing this
in the first place, the powders?
So the advantage can be, if you are trying
to lower your total caloric intake, for example,
then it's a very concentrated source of protein
for a small amount of calories.
So depending on the type of athlete,
that might be something that they're trying to do,
and therefore it has good utility.
That makes sense.
I'm a minimalist, relative minimalist
when it comes to supplements,
but I do have a protein powder, and I usually throw
a scoop or so into a smoothie that I have every day.
My recommendation for trying to choose one,
because there's so many on the market is,
firstly, 25 to 30 grams of protein in a serve as a minimum.
Sometimes you see some coming out now
and they're diluted down to 15, 16 grams.
You need 25, 30 grams as a minimum
to maximize muscle protein synthesis,
if that's your goal.
Secondly is, I like to look for one
that has the amino acid profile.
And this goes back to our trade off
we were talking about before,
because if you're an athlete
and you are looking to boost your performance,
then leucine is important.
And you can find one that has two
to three grams of leucine per serve,
and know that that's going to be a very anabolic protein.
So firstly, does it have enough protein per serve?
Secondly, looking at the leucine content.
Over and beyond that, I usually tell people
to find one that they enjoy.
They like the brand Ethos, it tastes good.
And they're kind of the two most important things
I'm looking at from a performance point-of-view.
There are a lot of different blends and different types,
you've got potato protein is now starting
to surface, pumpkin, you've got brown rice,
you've got pea protein.
You've got mung bean, fava, there's a whole lot coming out.
Yeah, we have hemp, Sacha Inchi, chia,
I'm seeing now, sunflower, all different kinds.
So yeah, I mean, my obvious question is
which one of those has the best profile
for athletic performance, or which one of those
has a better leucine profile?
Typically speaking, the pea protein,
brown rice protein blend is like
the plant-based whey protein.
That's the most common that you see.
It's the most common.
And it is for a reason in that
when you put those two together,
you get a very similar amino acid profile
to whey protein, so without over complicating things,
that's a great worthy option for anyone.
With that said, if you stick to the first two principles
that I said of 25 to 30 grams,
two to three grams of leucine,
then I'm not so concerned really what that blend is.
It could be a, it could be for four or five of those.
And I'm more interested at that point
in what someone likes in terms of palatability.
And therefore they're going to be happy with,
including into their diet every day.
There's gotta be differences in absorption
as well, whey versus these plant alternatives.
And then amongst the different varieties
of plant proteins in terms of how well
the body can uptake these nutrients.
Yeah, you would be surprised when you isolate
the plant protein in any of these forms,
the absorption becomes almost comparable with whey,
and we're talking up into the 90% absorptions
in these isolated plant forms.
That's one of the big benefits of these.
They are very bioavailable and the difference
is probably only a couple of percent between them and whey.
And there are a bunch of randomized controlled trials
where they've compared whey with brown rice
and with pea, and looked at athletes
doing assistance training, and found no difference
between the two arms where one arm was supplementing
with whey, and one arm was supplementing
with the plant protein.
So I wouldn't be concerned about the bioavailability of them
and the protein researchers that are not,
they're not plant-based, these guys are omnivorous.
They all tend to agree now that as long
as the protein serve is right, it's ticking the box,
and lutein is at two or three grams,
then there is no difference between the two.
That's a huge shift from not that long ago
in terms of, what the scientific community is saying.
Yeah, there were some ideas that you would need
to consume much more plant protein to get the same effect.
And that's largely now been debunked
by two or three different studies.
As I say, that have looked at these isolated forms,
as long as the leucine is matched.
I will say that that seems to be why whey protein
in particular is good, is that it's high in leucine, right?
So as long as that plant-based protein powder
is meeting that two to three gram threshold,
then you can be comfortable
you are not sacrificing anything.
One question I've always had is given
that what we're trying to do is ensure
that we're getting those nine essential amino acids,
and when we eat foods, we break down those proteins
into their respective amino acid components,
instead of a protein powder supplement,
why not take a supplement of aminos
or branch chain amino acids,
so that you're bypassing that step of breaking them down
and creating perhaps an even more absorbable form of
the building blocks of protein?
Like, is that an ignorant statement, or how does that work?
It makes logical sense, but remember, these proteins
also contain non-essential amino acids,
and non-essential amino acids are important
for muscle protein synthesis.
And so your body is making those,
but when you're wanting to build a lot of lean muscle,
having more of those is helpful.
So if you were just taking the BCAA supplement
or an essential amino acid supplement,
you're missing out on all of those non-essentials.
So that's probably the first point that I would make there.
And I think largely particularly the BCAAs,
right, is when you are just taking the BCAAs,
you're not getting any benefit at all over
and above protein powder.
So my advice to people is that you could add the BCAAs,
but for the same price, you could add a good protein powder,
which is providing all of those other non-essential
and essential amino acids that are still critical
for building muscle.
It's not as though just leucine
and valine for example, which are often two
that people talk about, are the only ones
that matter, all of them matter.
And so providing your body with a good mix of all of them
is sort of generally the school of thought
and the recommendation for the best result.
Interesting, so don't waste your money on BCAA.
I wouldn't waste your money on BCAAs
or isolated amino acids.
I would stick to just finding a protein powder
that provides all of the nine-plus non-essential amino acids
in varying amounts,
and it's gonna be much more cost-effective too.
Conventional wisdom for a long time,
was that there's this special window post-workout,
about 30 minutes, in which you should replenish your body
with protein and other certain nutrients, electrolytes,
et cetera, to optimize the reparative cycle.
Is that still the case, has science pivoted
in terms of how we're thinking about that?
I think there's something in timing for sure,
and how much protein you're having at each meal.
But I think that if we were to sort of prioritize things
first it's, at first it's exercise and the stimulus,
and then it's your overall diet,
and then it's total protein.
And then underneath that, it's the timing of the meals,
and how much protein you're having in each meal.
So I don't want to kind of get carried away on this
because it's less important,
but if you're really fine-tuning,
this is where this stuff gets more important.
And the current evidence suggests that firstly,
instead of having, say you have 120 grams of protein
in a day, instead of having all of that in one meal,
from a muscle protein synthesis point-of-view,
and from a strength point-of-view, recovery point-of-view,
it seems that you are much better breaking that down
into three or four meals.
Breaking it down, not to the point where you have less
than 30 grams of protein in a meal,
but splitting it out over multiple meals throughout the day.
And the reason for this is that each time you have a meal,
you can spike muscle protein synthesis with, if your meal
is rich in protein and leucine, but it has a ceiling.
So if you have 120 grams at one point in the day,
you'll spike it, you'll hit that ceiling,
and then you get nothing else for the rest of the day.
Whereas when you--
So that additional protein gets metabolized
in some other way that doesn't lead to--
It's to be used for the body anabolic effect.
Yeah, but it's not gonna have the anabolic effect
and result in as much growth, muscle growth,
and strength improvement, compared to when you divvy it out
30 grams and then three hours later,
another meal with 30 grams of protein,
and then three hours later,
and then maybe it's three or four meals across the day.
You get multiple spikes of muscle protein synthesis,
and overall an a greater net effect
of muscle protein synthesis in that 24-hour period.
I want to get into intermittent fasting and all of that,
but I don't wanna go too deep into that right now.
I want to stick on what we're talking about,
but I do have a question that is perhaps pertinent,
which is there some kind of positive adaptation
that can be had for periodic,
a periodic sort of fasted workout,
fasted state, where let's say one day a week,
you do a hard workout and you don't eat
until many, many hours later,
you're kind of putting your body into
a stress situation that creates a certain adaptation.
That is something you don't wanna do every day,
but is there a benefit to experimenting with that?
I think it's plausible from a hormesis point-of-view
and David Sinclair talks about this,
and perhaps that's a way of activating
these disease resistance pathways,
but anyone who's involved in the protein research
and lean muscle will tell you not to do that,
because it's probably a good way to go
into a sort of catabolic state.
And if you're trying to preserve muscle
and you're an athlete, then I don't think
that's going to be the strategy you're going
to want to pursue.
You're better off consuming meals regularly
throughout the day.
Mm, it's interesting.
I mean, from an endurance athlete perspective
and not being a scientist.
Like I have played around with this
and I've had an experience where it's sort of like, okay,
my body knows that it can do this hard workout
and not be fed for a very long time.
So in the future, when I find myself
in a situation of semi-depletion,
I feel like I can push past that.
And maybe that's just a mental barrier
that an experience like that allows me
to believe that I can do a little bit more on less,
but I have to believe some sort
of biological component to that.
It would be an interesting study to do.
To take some endurance athletes and change,
adjust their meal timing throughout the day
and measure some meaningful biomarkers.
But yeah, it's certainly not out outta the question
that there is some adaptation and some benefit
to doing that.
Again, I think it comes back to what someone's goals are.
And I think if you were sort of erring on
the side of caution of preserving lean muscle mass,
definitely the research shows that you don't want
to be in a fasted state for too long.
You start catalyzing your own muscle tissue,
which is not good.
Unless you're trying to get super lean.
Yeah, and look, if you're trying to get super lean--
But that's not a very healthy way of doing it.
It's not that healthy.
And I mean, judging someone's health by the outside
is kind of fraught with danger.
Especially if you're looking at lean muscle,
we know this, you only have to look
at bodybuilders and their life expectancy is not amazing.
That could be many things going on there,
including anabolic steroids.
That might have something to do with it.
Yeah, but point being is
that it's this entire conversation
around preserving lean muscle mass and maximizing strength.
I do think at the core of it is a trade off.
I believe that's where the research points to,
the more we wanna squeeze out of growth
and increasing our strength,
I think we are potentially sacrificing longterm.
Yeah.
Back to the subject of supplements for athletes.
I mean, and just to say it out loud,
I'm not somebody who's taking a crazy number of supplements.
I believe in responsible supplementation,
but I always kind of err on the lesser side,
like there's very few things that I take
with any regularity, but this is
an interesting conversation.
So aside from protein powders,
what are some of the other things
that athletes might benefit from?
And particularly plant-based athletes.
So we talked about nitrates and L Citrulline,
the other, I guess, two that we could talk about are,
or three, there's beta-alanine.
I never hear about this.
So there's beta-alanine, creatine, and caffeine,
before I forget, those three, along with nitrate.
So consistently in all of the consensus position papers,
looking at the best science,
they're the ones that surface
as having the most ergogenic effect.
Well, let's start with beta-alanine.
Sure, so beta-alanine, alanine,
or alanine, is anyone who's taking this,
or some people that have taken this will have experienced
some paraesthesia.
You get, you can get tingles in your fingers.
Like, like when you overdose on niacin?
Yeah.
And there's a trick.
Remind me, I'll come back to that when talk
about dosage to try and avoid that.
But in short, what is beta-alanine doing?
It seems to be most effective,
short, bursive, high-intensive exercise.
We're talking up to 25, 30 minutes,
the research hasn't really gone beyond that.
And at a mechanism point-of-view,
beta-alanine increases carnosine,
and carnosine, essentially is like, it's an antioxidant.
You can think of it of the way I like to think
about carnosine is it's sort of mopping up all of
the free radicals we produce while we're exercising,
cleaning them out, and helps reduce fatigue.
So you can perform a higher power longer.
And we see quite significant improvements in power
and strength with be beta-alanine supplementation.
It's the typical dose.
And again, I'll put this into a document for you,
but high level it's about four to six,
this one is grams, four to six grams per day.
And the timing of this one is interesting.
For a long time it was thought that you have
to supplement this right before you work out.
That's kind of been disproven, and you can now spread
the supplementation out or take it whenever,
the most important thing is that you're just saturating
your cells with it, similar to what happens with creatine,
so that your baseline levels of carnosine go up.
So four to six grams,
and you could take that in one dose,
but that is where quite a lot of people get this tingling.
It's like a hot rash, itchy, it's uncomfortable.
And it's often put into those like hardcore pre-workouts,
that's the ingredient that's doing that.
So the strategy there--
Like the crazy stuff at GNC
that comes in like a bright red can
or can plastic tub or something.
Yeah, and they have a whole lot of things in there.
I am not a big advocate of those.
I think you're better off trying some of these targeted ones
where it's a single ingredient, or like two
or three ingredients, and seeing.
Does it come in like a capsule form?
You can get capsule or you can get a powder.
Usually it's a flavored, raspberry or lemon, or something.
And if you wanna avoid that paraesthesia,
because you don't have to take this as one single bolus
before you work out, you split it.
So it could be two or three serves throughout the day.
And then usually there's that removes that side effect.
So that's beta-alanine.
That's one for people to consider.
Creatine is the kind of obvious one.
Yeah, that's I mean, most people have heard of that.
It's sort of typical amongst the bodybuilding crowd.
What's interesting about creatine.
I mean, first of all, it's very effective.
So I want to understand better why that is.
But in recent years, very recently,
there seems to be coming out about the impact
of creatine on depression.
It's sort of this mood elevator and perhaps has
a positive impact on cognition, which is super interesting.
Yeah, the brain health side of things.
And it seems that it's, creatine is depleted often
in people with schizophrenia or depression.
So it does have a role beyond muscle.
And I think that's been underappreciated
certainly for a long time, and maybe we start on
the cognition piece and then we go into the performance.
There has been, it's very limited science looking
at creatine and brain health.
That's the first thing I wanna say.
It's very early days emerging.
At the moment, the current state of the literature is
that protocols have not yet been identified.
It's too preliminary for that,
they're, they've identified,
which is very interesting, that creatine,
our neurons actually produce creatine,
and the creatine in our brain is separate
to the creatine in the body for the most part.
So there is also a lot of question marks over
whether you just supplement orally
and does that increase the creatine levels in the brain?
Does it pass the blood brain barrier?
Yeah, and it may be that if you have depression
or you have a condition that affects
the blood brain barrier, it does cross,
or that it only crosses if you have depleted levels
in the brain.
And that is a very ongoing area of research.
So I think it's a watch the is space,
there could be some utility there,
there's something going on.
There have been talks of vegetarians in particular,
perhaps benefiting from creatine supplementation
from a cognitive point-of-view.
And the theory there is that, well, animal products
do contain a little bit of creatine.
Your body, it's not an essential compound.
Your body does make it, but there is some advantages,
at least from a performance point-of-view,
to have a bit more in your body
over and above what it makes,
and animal products do contain a little bit of creatine,
not enough to fully saturate the body with creatine,
unless you're gonna have two kilograms of meat or something.
But there has been this school of thought that
because there is some creatine coming
in through animal products,
perhaps vegetarians could benefit
from creatine supplementation
from a cognitive point-of-view.
And there's two studies that have come out
that I think are interest you to talk about here,
because I do think this is a little bit misunderstood.
The first is, and I think the most important is,
they have done neuroimaging and scanned
the brains of vegetarians and omnivores.
And they've been able to see that the creatine levels
in the brain are exactly the same, which is really,
really interesting.
And that probably is back to what I said earlier,
that our neurons are actually synthesizing creatine
separate to the rest of the body.
So that's different to what we see in muscles.
In muscle tissue, you see vegetarians
have less creatine than omnivores,
and which is one of main reasons why vegetarians potentially
have a better performance effect
from creatine supplementation.
There's a study that came out 2010
by a researcher called Benton,
and this is the kind of study that everyone cites,
looking at cognition between vegetarians
and omnivores with creatine supplementation.
So it was a randomized controlled trial, placebo.
And what they showed is there was a significant difference
in cognition between the vegetarians and the omnivores
that were supplementing with creatine.
But this study is misinterpreted.
So let me run through--
So this is the study that gets thrown around
on social media to establish that vegetarians
have some kind of brain problem?
Yeah, so let me just walk through exactly how,
how they did the study.
And we can just think about the findings here.
So baseline, they tested the cognition of the omnivores
and the vegetarians.
This was before supplementation, and this test,
this was a recall test.
So you're going to hear 30 different words.
And then you've got two minutes to write them down.
As many as you can, that was the cognitive domain.
It's a memory test.
At baseline, there was no difference between the two groups.
So the vegetarians and the omnivores
performed exactly the same.
Then they did creatine supplementation.
And this was a higher dosed creatine protocol
than what you would do for performance,
it was 20 grams a day over about a week period.
And they performed a test again.
And in that test,
the vegetarians performed as they did at baseline,
but the omnivores performed really poorly.
So there was a significant difference
between the two groups, but it wasn't driven
by the vegetarians performing poorly.
It was driven by the omnivores performing poorly.
So something about the creatine supplementation decreased
the omnivores' cognitive.
Perhaps, it was a very surprising finding.
And I think it's being misinterpreted.
As there's a vegetarians are deplete in creatine
and when you add it to their diet, their cognition improves.
That's not what the study showed.
Their baseline and their retest was exactly the same.
For some reason, the omnivores' performance
dropped off and that's what created
the significant difference.
So that's the Benton 2010 study, and Hamilton Roschel,
who's a big researcher in this space,
he just published a review called,
"Creatine and Brain Health."
It's fantastic for anyone to read about all of this.
And he essentially speaks about
the misinterpretations of that study,
talks about the fact that vegetarians
and omnivores have the same levels of creatine
in their brains on scans, and finishes by saying,
we need further research because for now we can't see
a significant reason for vegetarians to be supplementing
with creatine for brain health.
Hmm, that's fascinating.
So how does it get perverted and turned
into this narrative that gets thrown around
to kind of a line, you know?
I'm not sure it's intentional.
I think that if you'd sort of just look at one side of
the study and you've disregard the baseline,
and you just look at the two bars on this graph,
you see the vegetarians performing really well
compared to the omnivores.
So I think it's just a misinterpretation of the data
more than anything, but it, what it does say
is there's no reason to be alarmed
that if you're a vegetarian or a vegan
and you're not supplementing with creatine,
that you're going to have a cognitive deficit,
that science does not show that.
And while there will be more science done,
I think down the track, if they work out
a way to increase creatine levels in the brain
for certain conditions, whether it's schizophrenia
or depression, I think omnivores and vegetarians
will likely benefit in a similar manner.
Have they done studies on depression specifically?
Because you spoke about cognition,
but depression is an altogether different thing.
I haven't seen any of the data in terms
of supplementing people with depression
with creatine and seeing outcomes.
I can look into that.
But what I've seen is that people with depression
often have lower levels of creatine.
And I believe certainly the conclusion
of Hamilton Roschel's paper was
that we need far more information.
And even for conditions like depression and schizophrenia,
there is there's no science to date that gives us
very clear confidence to recommend a certain protocol
of supplementation for these people.
Got it.
So in the context of athletic performance,
there's some anabolic effect to creatine.
So walk me, help me and everybody understand what that is.
I guess, put simply, our body uses glucose
or carbohydrates into glucose that enters our cells.
People will have heard of the mitochondria,
and this is like the energy factory.
And through a whole sort of complex set
of biological reactions, we turn this glucose into ATP
and creatine allows you to produce more ATP.
And that is allowing you then,
to increase your power and your strength.
And the benefit of that is
that you can increase your training volume,
then therefore, get greater adaptations.
So it's not a situation
in which it just grows your muscle,
it just allows you to push harder, go longer?
And then as a result of that, gets stronger,
faster, et cetera.
For the most part, you will get a little bit of
a filling out with the water retention,
that can kind of make you feel a bit fuller.
Puffy.
Yeah, and some people
like that look, and others don't.
And I've definitely, the feedback I've had from,
in some endurance athletes is they don't like that.
And they think it works against their performance,
carrying that extra sort of water retention.
But by and large, it is just allowing you to do more work.
You get a greater stimulus
and then therefore greater adaptations.
And it's one of the safest, most studied ingredients,
safety up to 30, 30-plus grams per day with no side effects,
other than some gastrointestinal upset
in certain individuals.
So something to be aware of, but it's not that common,
certainly not as common as sodium bicarbonate,
which is another supplement that I really don't recommend
because it causes a lot of gastrointestinal upset,
even though it is quite ergogenic,
but creatine seems to not affect
that many people in that way.
And the dosing has, the recommendations have changed
over the years, used to be thought
you need to have a high dose, 20 grams a day,
for about a week, that will saturate your cells.
And then you can drop to
a maintenance dose of five grams per day.
That still is an option.
The, it's now also been shown that if you just jump straight
to five grams a day, by four weeks in,
you will have saturated your cells.
So you can choose your own adventure there.
Interesting.
I mean, I would think that much
like a bodybuilder has a bulk phase
and a lean phase, that an endurance athlete
could benefit from this by using it
during heavy training periods or training camps
to get the adaption, adaptation effects,
but then cycle off of it where they can lean out
and lose some of that water retention
that creates unnecessary, a weight drain,
where power to weight is so important
and that's in those sports.
Yeah, I think that makes sense.
And that's probably also what bodybuilders do
and when they're trying to lean out they jump off of it.
So, certainly there's nothing wrong
with using it like that in a sort of cycling,
cycle on, off fashion.
Right, and it does seem like it's safe.
I mean, is it, how do they manufacture it?
What is it comprised of?
That's a great question.
I always wonder,
I always assumed it wasn't a vegan product
because you associate creatine with--
Yeah, you certainly can get vegan creatine, 100%.
And the more and more now you're seeing brands
that are selling vegan creatine will have that on the label.
So I know that certain possible.
It's probably, it's synthetic,
so it's probably made in a laboratory.
Right, but relatively, basically
on the safer side of supplements that you're gonna take.
Definitely the, I mean, in all of
the different consensus positions,
it is considered the most studied
and the safest of all of these various supplements
that we're talking about.
The final supplement, it's not really a supplement.
I mean, you have coffee, like--
Caffeine.
We all know that is an athletic performance enhancer.
I've had such a, I've been off caffeine,
I go back, and then I'm like, I'm training.
And it's like, well,
if I drink a cup of coffee before this workout,
I know I'm gonna have a better workout.
And then suddenly I'm back on coffee.
Yeah, you can, some people have a love,
hate relationship with it.
Some people do really poorly on caffeine,
which we should know where they feel anxious.
And they're certainly someone
that I wouldn't recommend supplementing caffeine
or loading up on the coffee.
Other people are severely,
their sleep is severely disturbed.
Yeah, Matthew Walker talks about that.
Like even, one cup of coffee at eight o'clock
in the morning has an impact on your ability
to get a restful night's sleep that evening.
Exactly.
And the really interesting thing is there's
a genetic component to that.
So how quickly your audio metabolizes caffeine
is highly variable.
So you do hear some people say, I can have a coffee,
midday one, o'clock, two o'clock and I'm fine.
And others, they just cannot sleep.
It's also an age thing too.
Like when I was 24, I could probably drink
a cup of coffee after dinner and fall asleep fine.
And now if I did that, I would be,
there's no way I would sleep.
Yeah, I mean, I don't think I could sleep
with a coffee after midday.
And the research looking at this seems
to suggest there's a few different mechanisms happening,
but one is, it makes you sort of hyper-vigilant,
more alert, but very interestingly,
it seems to lower your perceived level of exertion.
So you don't feel as if you're working as hard,
which often we put a limit on what we can do
just through what we think,
not physically what we can achieve.
And perhaps it allows us to tap
into more of our physical capability.
That's one of the ideas.
And from a performance, ergogenic point-of-view,
the research really zooms in and narrows in
on this three to six milligram per kilogram
of body weight dose as being
the sort of clinically-effective dose.
And when you ramp up and you go
above nine milligrams per kilogram,
there doesn't seem to be any extra benefit.
And that's where you start to see more of
these side effects, like anxiety, gastrointestinal upset,
affecting sleep.
So something to be mindful of there.
So for someone who is, let's say 70 kilograms,
and you can convert all these.
I don't know how much, I have no idea what that means.
I think, I think roughly,
and I don't have a calculator here,
but we're talking sort of 150 pounds, okay.
For someone of that size, if we were
to take six milligrams,
we're looking at a dose of 420 milligrams of caffeine,
which really is not going to be achieved through coffee,
unless you have a whole lot of coffee.
One shot is usually,
one shot of coffee is about 60 milligrams.
So to get up to that three, 400-odd milligrams
to sort of get maximum performance effect,
you need to look to the supplements
that have caffeine in their formulas.
That's not saying though that at the lower end of the range,
three milligrams per kilogram,
you're still getting a benefit as well.
So I think that's one usually that people need
to play around with and find what is most comfortable,
and work from there.
Yeah, too much.
And your toast.
Yeah, I don't think I would cope very well,
to be honest at the high dose of,
at that sort of 450 milligram dose of caffeine,
I perform much better at about half of that.
Yeah, but on the adage of energy,
can neither be created nor destroyed,
like you're essentially borrowing energy, right?
You're creating a debt that you're gonna have to repay.
So how hefty is that debt repayment?
Like, are you, if it's all about like,
I need to have the best performance possible
on this particular day and that's your priority,
then caffeine can certainly help produce that result.
But if you're trying to perform day in, day out
in a heavy training period, you're gonna run
into some kind of drained situation that perhaps
is gonna undermine the greater goal that you're seeking.
But definitely if it's affecting your sleep
and you're not nourishing your body to supply
the nutrients and calories that you need
through being able to have achieved greater output.
I think, certainly that's the case.
I would say overall,
like if we thought about coffee for a moment here,
instead of just caffeine, again, it's not for everyone,
certain people do not do well on coffee, but overall,
the research looking at coffee and cardiovascular disease,
and neurodegenerative disease, is quite positive.
And just like tea, three to sort of five cups a day
is associated with better health outcomes.
And there are a number of mechanisms that help explain
that, one of which being polyphenols.
So, I think there's a place for this within a program,
but we need to be cognizant of the fact that
it can really affect your cortisol levels,
your stress, can affect your sleep.
So you need to find that happy balance where you're getting
the performance outcome that you're looking for
and also the recovery and downtime that you're looking for.
What are some of the common supplements
that you see people taking where you think like,
well, this is garbage.
Like, why are people doing that?
You know?
Well, that's usually
what I say about branched chain amino acids.
Right, so we talked about that.
Are there others that fall into that category?
I mean, what about MCT oil in the coffee?
That's a big one.
Is there a benefit to that?
I mean, certainly it's a lot of calories,
but in that vein of practices or things that are popular
at the moment right now that you see people doing,
particularly kind of in the fitness world,
that you would like to disabuse people--
I mean, anything outside of creatine, L citrulline,
beta-alanine, caffeine, and nitrates
is, it's just worth noting
that there's very limited evidence.
Those are considered the five ergogenic supplements
with good grounded evidence.
They've been tested for both ergogenic effect
and also for safety.
So anything beyond there, look,
it doesn't mean that they don't work,
it just means that there's not a,
not a whole lot of data to sort of make a decision.
And therefore you are running
a sort of trial and error approach.
So you have to be able to justify the cost, and like MCTs,
there are people that swear by them and they,
MCTs don't raise cholesterol.
So I don't have a problem with people using MCT oil
if they think they're getting a benefit out of it,
then I've certainly got no judgment on that.
I guess I just wanna reiterate that there's probably not
a lot of data on many of those things.
A close cousin to supplementation
is quote, unquote, "superfoods."
I don't want to go too deep down a rabbit hole here.
We're tiptoeing into Darin Olien territory
a little bit, our mutual friend.
This is his backyard.
Yeah, like, but perhaps we could spend a minute or two,
like if you had to pick like the top performing,
like these are expensive, right?
Are we really gonna go and buy all this stuff?
Like where's our money best spent?
So if you had to choose, what are the kind of top performers
that might make their way into your routine?
Like, we've got chia seed.
Like I'm, I like chia, like mine would be chia seeds,
spirulina, moringa, and maca powder.
Yeah, so you, I mean, I have most of those on rotation.
I think the chia and the flax are great
for, particularly for plant-based seed is.
They're really rich in the.
And then hemp.
I mean, I would put hemp seeds in there.
Hemp seeds as well.
So we could say chia seeds, hemp seeds, flax,
they'd be right up the top.
Then you do have--
Flax need
to be ground though, right?
Otherwise, you're not gonna be able to absorb them.
They just pass right through.
And chia seeds really should be soaked
or ground as well for the same reason.
So that's something to be mindful of.
The other one that I use a lot is chlorella.
I mentioned it before it's loaded in iron.
So that's another kind of green powder
that you can throw in.
But I tend to not have too many more
than that and focus more on just
consistently getting lots of color through
the fruits and vegetables, and then
basing my diet around those, and whole grains,
legumes, nuts, and seeds.
But I certainly will have some of those on hand
and throw them into my smoothies.
Yeah, the one final thing that I would add is cordyceps,
particularly if you're an endurance athlete.
Because much like beetroot,
like that's the one thing that beetroot and cordyceps are
the two where I actually feel,
I can feel a noticeable difference.
Yeah, I've heard that, I haven't used cordyceps myself,
but I have heard that.
I've used lion's mane, and anecdotally speaking,
I feel like my cognition is better.
Focus is better.
With that, I also do like some of the mushroom powders,
like reishi powder.
Reishi, chaga, things like that.
Yeah, some of these powders are very rich
in prebiotics and there is some data
showing prebiotic effect of reishi
and improving microbiome composition.
So, some of those are neat and emerging.
All right, moving on.
We talked about plant-based milks earlier.
It used to be, you go to the grocery store,
maybe there was rice milk.
If you were lucky, there was soy milk.
Now there's just a proliferation
of every imaginable non-dairy alternative.
We've got, oh, we've got soy, rice, coconut, almond.
Which ones are best, what should we be looking for?
What should we be looking to avoid?
Like, how do you think about this?
Or do you just make it at home yourself?
Look, I don't tend to make it all at home myself.
I have done it, but I, you can fortify,
you can add calcium, for example,
at home with a red algae powder,
and you can so make your own almond milk
and then add the calcium in afterwards,
which is something that I know quite a few people will do,
but it requires a fair bit of effort.
So the store-bought ones,
there are a few reasons why I think they're good.
One is that I do think the calcium fortification
is important and we have to think
about someone's overall diet.
So if someone is looking to their milk
as a source of protein, and let's say it's providing
a very important source of protein
to that person's overall diet,
then when they make the swap to a plant-based milk,
they want to opt for one that is equivalent in protein.
And the obvious one is soy milk.
But now there are other alternatives
that are popping up, like pea milk, for example,
where both of those will have that sort of eight grams
of protein per serve, which is on par with the dairy milk.
So you have to know your overall dietary pattern
and what the purpose of adding this into your diet is.
If it's just being added to a coffee each day
in a very small amount, then that's a different conversation
because that person's going to want to look at it
more from a flavor and experience point-of-view.
But broadly speaking, I like to get people to look
for something that is as close to dairy milk
from a like, for like sort of perspective,
particularly if it's the main milk that they're going
to be drinking and have in their fridge for their family.
And so eight grams of protein and calcium fortification
at sort of that 100 milligrams per 150 mills.
So you can turn around and look per serve.
You should have around 300 milligrams of calcium
in a serve is exactly matched
for what you would get through dairy.
And then you're now starting to see, Rich,
some other plant-based milks pop up
that contain B12 and iodine, and vitamin D.
And again, whether you need these or not
really depends on back to our earlier conversation,
are you supplementing, are you getting enough--
Right, what does the rest of your diet look like?
On top of that,
you also have to learn how to read the labels.
Like a lot of these things have added sugar
and it's back to a conversation
around preservatives, emulsifiers,
all of these other things that go into creating
that texture that you're looking for in these products.
So some are more natural than others.
If it's, a lot of them have a lot, have added sugar.
I usually go for the unsweetened version.
That is, most brands will have, not all,
but a lot of them have a sweet version and an unsweetened.
Sure, and then there's the fat content as well.
Like a coconut milk is gonna be higher
in fat then the others, right?
Yeah, so if you are trying to limit your saturated fat,
then you're probably going to lean more
towards a pea milk or a soy milk.
And soy has particular properties actually,
that's very good for lowering cholesterol.
We can talk about that if you want at some.
People get freaked out when you talk about soy though.
Yeah, so that's why I like to state
and they don't need to get freaked out about soy,
but I understand that there is quite
a lot of stigma around it.
But the high quality science we have
suggests people don't need to fear it,
but for whatever reason,
some people don't want to consume soy.
And so I would look for other options,
like the pea milk that is comparable to dairy
in terms of overall protein content.
Oat milk seems should be killing
the game right now though.
Oat milk's great.
And it's, the reason it's going so well is
it's incredible in coffee.
It's very creamy.
My only sort of criticism,
if that's the right word, of oat milk,
is that if you are looking for something
that is comparable to dairy from a protein point-of-view,
if, for example, you want this to be one of
the sort of high-protein plant foods
that you are going to eat in the day,
then that's not the case for oat milk.
So just something to be aware of.
Mm, what about almond milk that you make at home
in three seconds in the Vitamix or cashew milk?
It's so easy.
Once you figure out how to do that.
It's easy, and my recommendation is if you do that,
then that's fantastic.
I would buy a red, you can buy red algae powder.
So back to the superfoods we were talking about,
and I would put red algae powder in, and red algae powder
is super constant traded in calcium.
You can't taste it.
And all of a sudden that transforms your milk
that you are making at home to one
that is packed with calcium.
Mm, that's a great hack, I never heard of that before.
And it's actually quite cheap.
And this one, I will name a brand
because I know it on the top of my head.
I think it's called NOW Foods
and they sell on Amazon around the world.
And they, at least they used to, when I last looked at this,
have a powdered form, not just a capsule.
So you can just dose that in at about,
you want to dose at about 1,000 milligrams of calcium
for one liter.
M'kay.
In the way that people get freaked out
when you talk about soy or soy milk,
people also get freaked out when the topic,
the subject turns to grains, right?
Whole grains are an important part of a healthy diet,
certainly a healthy whole food plant-based diet,
but then people lose their minds.
They're like, how can, grains are the devil,
grains are the worst thing that you could be eating?
How could you possibly say that I should be eating grains?
Yeah, so this comes back,
I think, the best sort of on-ramp here
or departure point to explain this is probably
that carbohydrates is an umbrella term.
And we often see all these different foods lumped
under the one sort of umbrella,
as well that's a carbohydrate-rich food,
it must be bad for our health.
And that stems from the most heavily processed cereal
to brown rice and quinoa,
and we see all these foods bucketed
underneath the same sort of umbrella.
And in reality, they have different effects on our health.
I think it's important to understand what's the difference
between a refined grain and an unrefined,
and takes me back to university.
I used to think the word beg.
So B stands for brand, E stands for endosperm,
and G stands for germ.
This describes the three layers of a whole grain,
and really the brand,
the outer layer is where most of the fiber is.
And then the endosperm in the middle is sort of
the largest component is just the starch carbohydrate part.
The white bread part.
Yes, and then the right deep, deep in,
there's the germ, and the germ is where
a lot of the antioxidants and phytochemicals, vitamins,
and minerals are, and in a refined grain,
you just have the endosperm, the middle layer.
So you just, you get rid of
the nice high-fiber outer casing,
and you get rid of this very nutrient-dense germ
from the middle, and you're just left with the starch.
Okay, so you can imagine, another analogy here is all of
a sudden, you've got your carbohydrates are naked,
they're not wearing their clothes anymore.
And whereas the whole grain is providing much more fiber,
much more antioxidants, phytochemicals,
vitamins, and minerals.
And they have very different effects on our physiology,
from how they're metabolized,
how they affect our gut microbiome.
If you're eating refined grains,
you're foregoing that fiber that you could have had,
and therefore, you're not feeding your microbes
at the same time.
So they are very different.
I like to point people to brown rice and wild rice,
and buckwheat and amaranth and barley.
These are all really, really healthy whole grains
that we should be including in our diet.
They are consistently associated
with better health outcomes, with longevity.
And usually I like people to be getting
at least three serves of those per day,
a serve being sort of half a cup of rice or quinoa,
or two pieces of whole wheat bread, for example.
And if you're doing that, you are absolutely
overall improving the overall healthfulness of your diet.
Okay, so for the consumer,
going to the market problems ensue,
because the there's a lot of confusion
about what constitutes a whole grain
versus a refined grain,
and there's a lot of marketing shenanigans
that go on into masking, what is a refined grain,
and trying to advertise it as something more
in the vein of a whole grain.
And so I think people are trying to make informed choices
and are often let astray.
So how do we know, like for example, bread,
like talk about bread a little bit,
because I think people would be amazed
to hear like, what goes into this?
Well, I used to just pick up
any sort of multi-grain bread.
Like if it's just on the darker side is probably better.
And if you can say some seeds.
I thought that was how you choose
a healthy bread, for a long time.
And it's probably not the best way of trying
to decipher what's healthy, what's less healthy.
And I like to point people to think
about two different things when trying to choose
a bread, but some of this applies
to just any food in a package.
The first is that the first ingredient written
on the bread on the ingredient list is very important,
very, very important.
Enriched flour.
If it's enriched flour,
then you know where all of a sudden we've jumped
into refined carbohydrate territory,
and that's probably going to be a product we want
to skip and look for something else.
Enriched is such an interesting choice of words.
It should be deprived flour or something like that.
I know it's a positive spin.
Impoverished, come on.
I don't blame them for using that word.
But the first word is very important.
We don't also, we also don't wanna see wheat flour,
wheat flour tricks a lot of people.
What you wanna see is
the first word is whole, whole wheat flour,
whole wheat grain, whole meal.
The very first part of that word should say whole.
Good luck finding that.
So there's almost no, you're, I mean, it's very difficult.
We're narrowing the field, but it's definitely,
it's definitely positive, definitely possible
to find one.
And the second thing I like people to look at,
which is really the final thing,
the two of these togethers works very well
to identify healthy bread,
is looking at the carbohydrate to fiber ratio.
So what we wanna see is a ratio of five to one or better.
So by that, what I mean is, if per serve
you have 20 grams of carbohydrates,
I wanna see that that product
has four grams of fiber or more.
That's a very good indicator, again,
that what we are dealing with here is
a less-refined product.
That goes for anything in a wrapper and also for breads.
That's interesting, I've never heard that before.
That's a good-- (crosstalk)
Attribute that, because, you who told me that?
Dr. Greger.
Spot on?
So that's some of Dr. Greger's magic.
And I think when you think about that,
plus you think about that first ingredient,
it is a very, it's a very quick
and easy way to identify a sort of unhealthy bread
or a less healthy bread, to one that is truly giving you
that serve of whole grains, which is what we're after.
So if you find that bread that begins
with the word whole and has the appropriate ratio,
that has an okay place in your routine
in terms of eating that kind of bread?
So if you find that, we need not vilify bread
as a blanket term, we can have that
and feel like we're nourishing ourselves on some level.
And we only have to look to the Sardinians,
centenarians in Sardinia.
They regularly eat bread.
They have whole meal sourdough,
which is one of my favorite breads.
I want, sourdough is interest,
it's a white bread, but it's actually,
I mean, there's a difference between,
is there a difference mean the sourdough
that you buy in the grocery store versus like
the homemade sourdough, which is like a whole thing?
Well, I think the big difference we're talking
about here again, is that starting grain.
Is it whole, or is it refined?
A lot of the sourdough that you would pick up
just off the shelf is not whole meal derived,
it's not a whole meal base in that recipe.
So trying to find a whole meal sourdough
can be a little tricky.
I know a couple places, for example, in Sydney,
one just happens to be down the road for me,
that I was able to locate,
but it's something people can look out for.
But you will be able to find a whole meal bread in general.
And the other one to point out here is there's
a whole nother sort of class of breads,
Ezekiel sprouted breads, and these,
they are sprouting whole grains.
This is Doug Evans-approved.
This is absolutely Doug Evans-approved.
So that's a whole nother option.
You can look for the sprouted quinoa,
or sprouted flax, or any type of sprouted bread,
or a Ezekiel bread is another great option.
And I tend to rotate through sort of whole meal bread,
whole meal sourdough, with an Ezekiel.
If the bread is in the freezer section,
as opposed to the bakery section, in my mind,
that's a good place to start.
Like if it has to be refrigerated,
there's something alive in there
that maybe would warrant a deeper look.
For sure, I think that's another good tip.
If your priority is lowering your cholesterol
or losing weight, like how do we, understanding
that there's no one-size-fits-all plant-based diet.
We talked about athletes,
we talked about some general principles.
How do you modify your approach to your plant-based diet
to achieve weight loss or lower those markers?
Usually when I talk about cholesterol lowering,
I point it to a series of recommendations
from an MD in Canada called Dr. David Jenkins.
And he has developed, what's called the Portfolio Diet.
Some people may have heard of this before.
It's a plant-based dietary pattern,
and it focuses more on what you are adding.
It's got four steps to it, and it's been clinically shown
in randomized controlled trials, to lower your cholesterol
by 30-odd percent.
And really that's not going full plant,
that's coming from an omnivorous diet.
So if you were to go full plant
and tap into these four recommendations even more,
then the cholesterol lowering could arguably be above 30%.
And I've certainly seen that
with the number of people I've worked with.
So the first recommendation of the four
in the Portfolio Diet, and I'll give you a PDF,
I have a beautiful PDF summary of this,
from Dr. David Jenkins.
First step is a couple of small handfuls of nuts per day.
So that could be walnuts, could be pistachios,
could be almonds.
It could be a serve of nut butter,
which is a tablespoon or two.
It's interesting, I wouldn't intuitively associate those
with lowering cholesterol.
So let me tell you what's happening there.
Nuts consistently have been shown
in the literature to lower cholesterol.
And the reason for that is their unsaturated fat content,
particularly the polyunsaturated fats,
which, as opposed to saturated fat
which increases cholesterol, unsaturated fats,
particularly at the poly unsaturated fats,
lower cholesterol.
So that's what's happening there.
The second recommendation in the Portfolio Diet is to have
at least two to three serves of plant protein per day,
ideally with a few of those being from soy foods.
So this overall, could be two or three serves from lentils,
chickpeas, tofu, tempeh, these sorts of foods.
The reason for a recommendation to include some soy foods
within that, edamame, for example, or tofu,
is that they do have a particularly good way
of lowering cholesterol, and--
That's unique to soy.
That's unique to soy and it's probably driven
actually through polyphenols,
the phytoestrogens, which is the,
what everyone sort of refers to them as,
they're actually isoflavones, which are polyphenols.
And it does seem that about one in two people
have a particular microbiome composition
where they can convert these compounds
into a compound called equol,
which is providing many benefits throughout the body.
So two to three serves
of plant protein being tip number two.
And remember that this is for most people,
coming at the expense of red meat and chicken.
The third recommendation is to have five serves
of fruits and vegetables per day,
five serves of fruits and vegetables per day,
which is well above what the average intake is.
And with a bias towards fruits and vegetables
that have a lot of soluble fiber, viscous fiber,
that pulls bile out of the digestive system,
and in doing that, helps to lower cholesterol.
These sort of viscous foods are like eggplant, okra.
We've got berries are another great one, apples,
so these sorts of foods.
And then the fourth tip is,
or fourth recommendation within this Portfolio Diet is
the consumption of plant sterols.
So these are a phytochemical that essentially blocks
the absorption of cholesterol.
And you can do this.
There are some products that are fortified
with these plant sterols, but probably the best
and easiest way to do this, because you need two grams
of these plant sterols per day to be clinically effective,
that's shown in randomized controlled trials,
is to take a supplement.
And there's a bunch of different brands offering them,
and they're pretty much always at two grams per serve
because that is the clinically proven dose.
So those are the four sort of recommendations that
on the aggregate, lead to a 30% reduction
in your LDL cholesterol,
which is the atherogenic cholesterol
that contributes to the fatty plaque being laid down
in our arteries, and then in a heart attack or a stroke.
I would say, because that can be quite a significant drop,
if you are currently on medications,
you should be doing this under
the supervision of your physician.
You should at least let them know that, look,
I'm gonna be changing my diet.
And you could point to this PDF that I will provide.
At which point the doctor says, go for it.
It's not gonna make any difference.
Your statin is always gonna be your statin.
Right, and you might be the first person
that goes back and surprises them.
But the point of keeping them across it is
that it may well affect your dose of your medication.
Right.
It seems like these are well, two things, first,
by eating these foods, you kind of crowding out
the other foods that might take up space on your plate.
So it's not about what you're eliminating,
it's about focusing on these new things.
And then suddenly, there's no room
for all those other things
that are elevating your cholesterol.
But beyond that, with the exception of maybe amping
up your fruit and vegetable intake,
these seem like principles that are good for anybody,
whether you're trying to lower your cholesterol or not.
100%, yeah.
And, overall, it's just shifting people
to a whole food plant-based dietary pattern.
It's just that it has, that specific protocol
has been tried and tested, and has shown
to result in this very clinically meaningful drop
in cholesterol, which is equivalent to low dose statins.
So that 30% reduction is very significant.
For the average person that's taking their cholesterol
from 130, which as we established is well above optimal,
down to 90 or around 90, which is a moving
in a very favorable direction.
And this is something that has been proven out.
Plenty of people have done this effectively.
Lower their--
Many different studies tried and tested.
And in fact, it's so tried and tested
that most physicians, if presented with this,
will be well aware of it.
It's a very commonly understood protocol
and has now influenced some of
the national cholesterol-lowering dietary guidelines.
Oh, that's good to hear.
How would this differ if weight loss is the priority,
beyond the obvious, like maybe reduce your portions.
Like, what are the kind of tweaks that you're gonna make,
if that's your goal?
Firstly, understanding calorie density is important.
In my book, I separate foods
into sort of low calorie density,
medium calorie density, high calorie density, and very high.
And the low calorie-dense foods are pretty
much all of your fruits and vegetables,
other than say dates and avocados,
which are very healthy foods,
but are just a bit more calorie-dense.
So in that low-calorie sort of food table,
I have all the fruits and vegetables.
It's got the dark leafy greens.
It's got the cruciferous vegetables,
like broccoli and cabbage, and broccolini.
It's got pretty much all of your various fruits.
It's got mushrooms, and it also has tofu in there.
And usually if someone comes to me and they're wanting
to lose weight, let's say that's their goal,
that's right for them.
First, I check, are they eating according
to sort of the plant-based food pyramid
that I have in there, or has a whole lot
of ultra processed foods snuck in,
which sometimes can happen.
In which case you just remove those and you barely have
to worry about anything else, and it takes care of itself.
Right, those are hyperpalatable
and they're driving that excess consumption.
And we can't control the environment around us,
but we can try as best as possible to control
the environment in our four walls.
And at least make it harder,
and create more resistance to consuming those foods.
So if they're not in the house,
if the ice cream's not there,
you have to overcome a lot of resistance
to jump into the car when you get the craving.
Calorie density,
back to those four different sort of groups,
are plant-based foods, whole foods, whole plant-based foods.
My recommendation is to really load up on those fruits
and vegetables, particularly before your main meal is
a way of filling up, and it will improve your satiety
before you get more of the calorie-dense foods
on your plate.
And one of the sort of superstars
that often people are surprised by here, is potato.
It's, potato is a much malaligned food,
largely because we fry it and turn it into chips.
But if you just take the sort of boiled or baked potato
and look at that, it is a very satiating food.
It's low in calories.
So it's a great way to feel full on fewer calories.
And it actually has a lot more nutrients
than people realize, like even the average russet potato
is pretty good.
If you just don't put a ton of butter on it, or sour cream
or whatever, and just eat it for what it is, it's filling.
This is something Chef AJ talks a lot about, like,
if you just increase those low calorie density foods
that are super high in fiber, you can fill yourself up.
And I think kind of pre-loading before your meal
so that you don't go into a meal starving,
you're in a better place to make better selective decisions.
Definitely.
That's great advice.
Like big salads before you go into your main meal.
Cauliflower is another one in there.
And being aware of the hidden calorie bombs.
Like what dressing are you using?
What is the, it's all in the sauces
and all the other stuff that seems benign,
and those are the real killers.
And there, so there's a study
that speaks pretty much to that
out of John's Hopkins, that looked at
how many extra calories does someone consume
if they eat out like five, six times a week,
versus someone who cooks at home almost every day.
And they were able to determine that
that person eating out just five or six meals a week,
were eating on average 1,000 calories more per week,
which over the course of the year is equivalent
to around seven kilograms of butter.
So, and probably what's happening there is
that in restaurants and in cafes,
there are a lot of hidden calories in the--
Sure, they're just trying to make it taste good.
And they're not showing you a nutrition profile
on this food, and they're gonna slather it with stuff,
whether they tell you or not, for the most part.
The chefs call it SOS, salt, oil, and sugar.
And that's a--
That's what Alan Goldhammer calls--
It's a secret weapon for them
to make the food more appealing.
But with that said, if your goal is to lose weight,
trying to prep at home and have as much meals
that you are making yourself will give you better control
over what's in there.
Yeah.
Well, dude, we did three hours.
We had to do three hours again
because we did three hours last time.
Before we completely shut it down,
like any final thoughts or parting words for people?
I feel like we covered a lot here.
I think we gave people a lot of stuff to think about
and take home with them.
I think, in the first, in our first conversation,
we kind of established the science underpinning
a plant-predominant to exclusive diet being best
for human health.
And my entire thesis is, and I want to kind of
make this clear, 'cause I'm not sure I really spoke
to that, is that when you broaden the lens,
open up the aperture,
and consider how our food choices affect the planet,
and you consider what we are doing
to billions and billions of animals,
and the unnecessary pain and suffering
that they are inuring, experiencing,
and that none of us would likely swap places with them,
when you do that, it does create a compelling case
for adopting a diet that is as plant-exclusive as possible.
And I say, as plant-exclusive as possible,
rather than a sort of firm endpoint,
because we all have our own circumstances,
means, social circumstances.
And I'm aware that this will look different
for each individual.
So my message is about,
I have unconditional love for everyone,
no matter where they end up,
and it's not about perfection,
this is about adopting this imperfectly,
just like my diet is not perfect.
It's imperfect.
And we, rather than having a few people around
the world make improvements perfectly,
if we want to see great changes in public health,
if we wanna see great changes in planetary health,
if we want to minimize the unnecessary pain
and suffering that we're inflicting,
then we need billions of people doing this imperfectly.
So with that in mind, my message is
to let go of the perfection and take some pressure
off yourself, remove the self-judgment and just get started.
And that may be a small change,
such as just changing one component of your meal,
swapping red meat for lentils, but by getting started,
hopefully today or tomorrow, you start the momentum.
And I have full confidence in everyone
that as they get started and start to make these changes,
they will begin to feel better themselves,
and that is hugely motivating.
As is what you feel from a mental point-of-view.
And I have made this transition
and I was aware of the health benefits
that were up for grabs,
but what I was not aware of was how good it feels
to live more congruently and to align your actions
with your values and beliefs, and the peace that brings.
So start slowly, take some pressure off,
and I wish you all the best of luck.
Amen, brother, I have lots of thoughts,
but I think that you just ended it
so beautifully that I'm not gonna say anything more,
other than thank you, you're a gift.
It's been really fun hanging out
with you here in Los Angeles.
Hopefully we get to do it in Australia.
We'll see at some point, in the not too distant future,
If we let you in.
I really appreciate the level of care and precision
that you bring to your work, and the way
in which you acquit yourself and conduct yourself
in the digital space that as we all know, is kind of rife
with a lot of bad behavior right now.
And I always look to you as a lighthouse
and a guidepost for kind of setting, not only a tone,
but as somebody who cares about trustworthiness
in terms of what you choose to offer people
in the public space.
The book is "The Proof is in the Plants,"
available everywhere, it's a fantastic resource.
As I said, last time, it really is like
the comprehensive primer on all things plant-based.
It's so vetted with the science and really you don't need
to look any further than that book to answer any
and every question that you may have about this diet.
And that's it, man, to be continued, part two concluded,
but many parts unknown, yet to come.
We did it, I appreciate you.
Thanks, man.
Thank you.
Simon is gonna provide us with a list of resources
to support the statements made today.
Some PDFs, I guess, we'll include everything
that we can in the show notes.
So if you're interested in diving deeper, you can go there.
You can go to his book, you can go to his podcast,
"Plant Proof," and you can find Simon
on all the social media channels at "Plant Proof,"
well, @plant_proof on Twitter.
Same on Instagram.
The same on Instagram?
Okay.
And in those places, you're just, you're very active.
Like you share lots of stuff and every study
that you come across, and you're not afraid
to mix it up with people there and share your opinion.
And so it's a fun follow as well.
Thank you very much.
Yeah, man, it's been good.
Episode two, I think we did it.
We did.
So three on the horizon.
Peace, plants.
Proof.
(relaxing music)